GET STARTED. WELCOME TO THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST FOR OUR
FIRST HEARING OF THE EAR FOR
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
NUMBER FIVE ON PUBLIC SAFETY. I
HAVE BEEN ASKED TO RETURN
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION INTO THESE
HEARING HELP INSURE THE SAFETY
OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY WELL
ALLOWING FOR PUBLIC ACCESS TO
THE DISCUSSION. HE THEN ROOM
FOR THIRTY SEVEN WE ARE HAVING
TO PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING. WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS A
MINIMAL CONTENT IN THE STAFF.
AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN KEEP
SIXTEEN OF SPACING. THEY'RE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL
EVERITT BILLS HERE TODAY TO
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WILL
RESTATE THIS ONE PUBLIC COMMENT
AGAINST BUT IF ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WHICH TO
SPEAK. THEY WILL RAISE THEIR
HANDS AND I WILL ASK THEM TO
APPROACH A MICROPHONE. WE WILL
ALSO HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELEPHONE. WE WILL HAVE A
PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER WE'VE
HEARD ALL ITEMS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC RESPECT PHYSICAL THE
THEME AND NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU'LL HAVE ONE
MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU ONCE YOU'RE PUBLIC
COMMUNIST THAN OR RETURN TO
RECEIPT BUT PLEASE OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN APOLLO
EVEN THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATORS USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. THE PANELISTS
L. A. O. AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OUR PARIMAL LEE. IN THE
V. W. R. ROOM I ASK THAT
EVERYONE SILENCE ELECTRONIC
DEVICES AND PLEASE MAKE
YOURSELF WHEN YOU'RE NOT
SPEAKING THERE WILL BE NO VOTE
IN THE COMMITTEE TODAY. WITH
THAT I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
START THE SUBCOMMITTEE. ON AND
KICK OFF THE ASSEMBLY YEAR HERE
IN THE PAST DECADE THE STATE
HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
IN PUBLIC SAFETY REFORMS. WITH
AN EYE TOWARDS THE BEST
PRACTICES AND EVIDENCE BASED
REFORMS WE REDUCE OUR RELIANCE
ON INCARCERATION WITHOUT
COMPROMISING PUBLIC SAFETY. WE
HAVE PRAYERS I SEE MAURY
ABILITY SHIN AND RE ENTRY
SUPPORT AND POLICIES THAT ARE
TRAUMA INFORMED CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE AND AIMED AT
REDUCING RECIDIVISM. WE ALSO
WANT TO BE MINDFUL OF HOW WE
ARE SPREAD A SPENDING TAX
DOLLARS RESPONSIBLY. FOR THE
FOR THAT OUR PUBLIC FIFTY
DOLLARS ARE PRIORITIZED FOR
LONG TERM DURABLE INVESTMENTS
AND OF WAY TO WASTE. BECAUSE
WITHOUT SAYING THAT THE
PANDEMIC HAS BROUGHT UNIQUE
CHALLENGES IN UPCOMING HEARINGS
WILL BE DISCUSSING THE NUMBER
OF ISSUES INCLUDING THE STATUS
OF OUR TRIAL COURTS. AND ACCESS
CHALLENGES FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. STATEWIDE
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
COORDINATION PRISON CLOSURES
AND STAFF ACCOUNTABILITY
IMPRISONED FOR. WE'RE TO THE
SYRIANS WILL WE WILL GET AN
OVERVIEW OF THE CORRECTIONS
BUDGET IN HERE ABOUT THE COVER
NINETEEN IMPACTS AND THE PERSON.
DALY ON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ARE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS FOR
THE SUBCOMMITTEE AFTER EACH
PANEL A LITTLE BIT UP TO FIX
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS. DO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS. WHEN I MAKE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS TODAY. MISTER
JONES SAWYER THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND- IT'S A PLEASURE TO
HAVE YOU AS A NEW CHAIR AND-
SOMEONE THAT DOES BELIEVE
INTERNAL JUSTICE REFORM THE
MOST IMPORTANT- SOMEONE TO GET
INTO THE NITTY GRITTY GREED
DETAILS OF WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE AND SO- THOSE OF US WHO'VE
BEEN ON THE COMMITTEE BEFORE WE
WELCOME YOU WELCOME OUR NEW
MEMBERS TO THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS. THIS IT I CHAIRED THIS
COMMITTEE WHEN I FIRST CAME IN
AS A FRESHMAN SILVA I THINK IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT COMMITTEE IN
THE ASSEMBLY BECAUSE WE DO THE
KIND OF WORK THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE SHY AWAY FROM AND THAT
IS OPTIMAL GESTURES FOR THE
MOST IMPORTANT DEALING DIRECTLY
WITH- CDC ARE AND- WHAT GOES ON
THERE. SO I THINK THIS WHAT
WE'RE STARTING OFF WITH IT
LOOKING AT POPULATION
PROJECTIONS AND BUDGET AND THEN
REALLY THAT THE TOPIC THAT'S
JUST BEEN WITH US SINCE SINCE
ALL OF LAST YEAR IS COVERED
NINETY FIVE AND I THINK A LOT
OF TIMES WHAT GOES ON IN A
PRESENCE DOESN'T COME OUT UNTIL
WHERE THE PUBLIC CAN SEE HOW
WELL OR NOT SO WELL THAT WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DEAL WITH
THAT ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES
TO NOT ONLY THE INMATES BUT I'M
ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE PRISON
GUARDS WHO WORK THERE.
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ARE THERE
TO KEEP THE PUBLIC SAFE AND IF
WE'RE NOT DOING A VERY GOOD JOB
OF KEEPING THEM SAFE FROM
COVERT NINETEEN AND THEN AND
THAT IN TURN THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES WHEN THEY GO
BACK OUT- EMPLOYEE AT THE STATE
HAVE NOT DONE A VERY GOOD JOB
AND SO I'M ALSO WANT TO HEAR
FROM THE RECEIVER ABOUT QUALITY
MANAGEMENT AND PATIENT SAFETY
IN THE PCP- AGAIN- AS WE
HOPEFULLY GET TO A POINT WHERE
WE START TO WIND DOWN WE DON'T
WANT THE SUPER SPREADER
INCIDENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING AND CDC R. OF THE
CONTINUE AND NOT KEEP PACE WITH
US IN OUR RECOVERY. AND SO- BOB
I'M HERE TODAY TO DEFINITELY
LISTEN TO- THE PROJECTIONS THAT
ARE COMING OUT- BUT MOST
IMPORTANT AND I'VE JUST IN WITH
THIS I'M A FIRM BELIEVER THAT
WE DO TIS IN A WAY THAT IS
SMART THAT EVEN THOUGH WE MAY
HAVE THE POTENTIAL OF CLOSING
FOR THE PIPE PRISONS THAT WE DO
IT IN A WAY THAT MAKES SENSE WE
DO IN A WAY THAT CONTINUE TO
SAVE MONEY TO THE TAXPAYERS AND
WE DO IT IN A WAY THAT WE MAKE
SURE THAT THE- THE RESIDENTS OF
THIS OF CALIFORNIA ARE NOT
ADVERSELY IMPACTED. WITH THE
COLONEL JUSTICE SYSTEM THE MOST
IMPORTANT PUBLIC SAFETY SHOULD
BE NUMBER ONE AND I
DETERMINATION OF WHAT WE CLOSE
AND MOST IMPORTANT HOW WE CLOSE
IT BY THE GOES OUT TO NONPROFIT
WEATHER STAYS INTERNAL. TO LOOK
AT ALL THE WAYS THAT THIS CAN
BE DONE. SO WE DO A IN THIS WAY.
AND EVEN THOUGH THEY PUBLIC
OVERWHELMINGLY. WANTS TO CREATE
A SYSTEM. THAT TOTALLY- MOVED
EVERYONE OUT OF OUT OF PRISONS-
WE NEED TO REALLY THINK THROUGH
THAT SAID WE DO MAKE THAT
TRANSITION. IT IS THE BEST
TRANSITION WE COULD POSSIBLY
HAVE YOU SEEN A BENCHMARK FROM
OTHER PLACES. MR WE DO THAT DO
IT WISELY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER JONES SAWYER AND WE WILL
BE DISCUSSING PRISON CLOSURES
ON FEBRUARY THE TWENTY SECOND.
LOOK FOR A JOB DISCUSSION. BUT
BUT IF WELL THERE IS. I WAS
THE- THIS IS MY FIRST-
COMMITTEE MEETING VERSION
BUDGET SUB FIVE COMMITTEE
MEETING SO I'M EXCITED TO BE
PART OF CONVERSATION I WAS THE
NEWEST MEMBER UNTIL ARCHER
WOMAN HAS BECOME THE NEWEST
MEMBER CONGRATULATIONS I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR LEADERSHIP- I'M
YOU KNOW EXCITED TO SERVICE
COMMITTEE AT PROBABLY ONE OF
THE MOST CRITICAL TIMES FOR OUR
COMMUNITY WHEN WE TALK ABOUT.
ON THE BUDGET ITEMS AND PASSING
A BUDGET THAT MAKES SENSE FOR
CALIFORNIA- I'M PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN LEARNING MORE
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON IN OUR
PRISON SYSTEM RIGHT NOW ABOUT
B. WHAT THE ACTUAL CODE RATES
ARE I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
LEARNING ABOUT WHAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING TO MITIGATE AND
DECREASE- TRANSMISSION AND IN
THE PRISON SYSTEM AS WELL I'M
ALSO PARTICULARLY INTERESTED
AND- THE CONVERSATION AROUND
HELLO YES- WHICH IS VITALLY
IMPORTANT AS OUR COMMUNITIES
FACE WILDFIRE THREATS AS WELL
AS PS PS EVENTS- SO LOOKING
FORWARD TO. BEING PART OF A
CONVERSATION AT THE MOST
CRITICAL TIME I THINK- IN OUR
IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ARE MISTER. WERE
JUST TAKING COMMENTS ANY
MEMBERS WHO WITH. IS THAT A
CUTE EVEN. BEFORE WE GET
STARTED ORDERS THE SURE I'LL
JUST BE VERY VERY QUICK TO THE
POINT THERE'S SOME HUGE
CHALLENGES FOR US TO DEAL WITH
ESPECIALLY WITH THE AREA THE
PANDEMIC SPREAD THAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE PRISONS IS
PRETTY. DISCOURAGING OF THERE'S
JUST A LOT TO CONSIDER RIGHT
NOW AND- I JUST HOPE THAT WE
CAN- B. STEWARDS THAT OTHER
PEOPLE EXPECT US. AND WE HAVE
THE RIGHT PRIORITIES TO PROTECT
THE PEOPLE THAT ALL DESERVE TO
BE PROTECTED. THANK YOU I CAN
AGREE WITH YOU MORE- BUT THAT
SO THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR BEING
HERE PRESIDENT TO THEY WERE
GOING TO GET STARTED I HOPE AS
WE START WE START WITH AN OPEN
MIND- AND WE FOCUS ON THE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS NEEDS THAT THE
PANDEMIC IS BOB FORD. BUT WE
ALSO MULTI TASKING WE THINK
ABOUT LONG TERM WHERE WE NEED
TO GO BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND
AFTER THE PANDEMIC THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK THAT WE NEED TO DO
TO CREATE A MORE JUST SYSTEM
AND LOOK FORWARD TO THAT. FOR
OUR FIRST- AREA WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN OUR FIRST PANEL
DISCUSSION ON ISSUE ONE
POPULATION PROJECTIONS. AND A
BUDGET OVERVIEW FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. WE CAN HAVE OUR
WITNESSES. MADAM CHAIRPERSON
GARCIA AND THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
FROM THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
WITH YOU. CCAR'S POPULATION OF
DANGER AND ARE PROPOSED BUDGET
PRIORITIES. CAN YOU BOND WHICH
IS IN I'M SORRY CAN YOU PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME FOR THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND THEN HE BEGAN.
CATHLEEN ALLISON SECRETARY FOR
CCR THANK YOU CONTINI. OKAY. SO
ALL OF. WE TALK ABOUT OUR
POPULATION UPDATE AND OUR
BUDGET PRIORITIES ALL OF WHICH
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED AND GUIDED
BY THE ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. IN THE BUDGET ACCU
WHEN YOU'RE A COLLEGE PASSED
LAST YEAR WE ASSUMED OUR DAHLE
POPULATION WOULD BE AT A
1-002-200-0500 THIRTY SIX. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE YES WE KNOW
CO THAT HAS PERCENT OF THE
DEPARTMENT WITH AN
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGES AS
PART OF OUR MEDICATION EFFORTS
THE DEPARTMENT HAS TAKEN STEPS
TO REDUCE THE POPULATION. AND
INCREASE SOCIAL DISTANCING AS
WELL AS ISOLATION AND
QUARANTINE EFFORTS. OUR
POPULATION HAS REDUCED TO ITS
LOWEST FOR THIRTY YEARS. AND
THE PROPOSED BUDGET FOR YOU WE
ASSUME A POPULATION DECREASE OF
OVER 20% UNTIL. TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FOR THE
BUDGET ACT AS AS LATE AS LAST
WEEK OUR POPULATION WAS. NINETY
FOUR THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
SIX. WE HAVE ACHIEVED THIS
DECREASE IN A VARIETY OF WAYS
TO INCREASE THE LATEST CHICKEN
ENERGY SUPERVISION. ARE WE DID
SOME INITIAL RELEASES IN APRIL
DUE TO COPE AND FOLLOWED UP IN
JULY WE'VE BEEN IT BEGAN TO. OF
REDUCTION OF POPULATION
REDUCTION MEASURES. POLITICO
THAT THAT- CERTAIN CERTAIN
OFFENDERS- RELEASED ON THE
NATURAL ALSO CERTAIN OFFENDERS
WITH NON VIOLENT NON SEX
OFFENDERS NON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RECEIVED RELIEF OF- EARLY
RELEASE WE GET A VARIETY OF
MEASURES WE DID A SIX MONTH-
EARLY RELEASE FOR HER DOES THAT
I JUST SENT THAT SAME CRITERIA
AND THAT IS ONGOING. IN
ADDITION. TO THAT WE DID A
TWELVE MONTH TO RELEASE AGAIN
FOR NOT SIR. NON NON DOMESTIC.
AT VERY SPECIFIC AGAINST. AND
ALL OF THOSE- WE SUSPENDED
THAT- IN AUGUST BUT WE CAN KEEP
IT GOING FOR SEVERAL MONTHS SO
WE DID SEE SOME REALLY BIG
REDUCTIONS. IN ON JULY AND
AUGUST OF OUR POPULATION- AND
WE IN ADDITION TO THOSE WE NEED
TO WE DID HIRE SPECTACLE RADIOS
SO SECRETARY DEVOS BEFORE ME
DID SOME HIGH RISK MEDICAL
REVIEWS I SUBSEQUENTLY DID HIGH
RISK MEDICAL REVIEWS. OF ALL
THE WAY DOWN TO WHAT WE CALL
COMPLETE RISK FACTOR THREE- I
USE A VERY SPECIFIC CRITERIA
FOR THOSE OFFENDERS WHO HAVE.
COMPLETED THEIR PRIMARY CHARM.
SHE I WERE A LOSER- TERM
ENHANCED. I REFER- SEVERAL A
COUPLE HUNDRED TO. AT ASK FOR
THEM BE- CONSIDER. UNDER OUR
SEVENTY DEEP IN A COUPLE EVAN
SEVEN DF. FORTY I WORKED IT OUT
WE THE MYSTERY OF OFFICE A THE
CORE TO LEARN TO JUDGE THAT THE
WERE TECH OF WERE HIGH RISK
MOTHER CASE. THAT I WAS ASKING
SOME EXPEDITED RELIEF ON- THOSE
ARE STILL BEING EVALUATED THE
COURTS TODAY. IN ADDITION I
PERSONALLY EVALUATED ANYBODY
WHO WAS SERVING- HAVE BEEN
GRANTED- BY THE BOARD AND NOT
HELD BY THE GOVERNOR RELEASED
OUT OF- LIKE FIRST THAT WERE
RELEASED OUT OF PRISON. SHOULD
I TAKE THAT BACK THAT WORK
GREAT- WILL LEAVE BUT THEY IS A
SECOND TERM WHICH I AM ONE OF A
SECOND TRY WAS- SUCH. IN
PRESIDENT FOR SARAN NINETY
SEVENTY TWO SO I HAVE NO
PROBLEM SIGNING MY NAME TO A
HANDFUL OF THOSE UP FOR RELEASE
I SIGNED ALL BUT A COUPLE. I
AND THE COUPLE WERE G. YOU KNOW
RESET. OR SERIOUS STAFF OF THE
TYPE OF- IN ADDITION I'VE ALSO
REVIEWED CASES THAT ARE
INDETERMINATE LAY SENTENCED-
I'M SORRY I SAID- SAID THAT- IN
ADDITION WE ALSO HAVE PROP
FIFTY SEVEN SO THE CALIFORNIA
VOTERS APPROVED PROP FIFTY
SEVEN WHICH CREATED MORE
CREDITS AND INCENTIVES FOR
PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS. ALSO
ESTABLISH A PAROLE
CONSIDERATION PROCESS SERVING
FOR NON VIOLENT OFFENDERS- PROP
FIFTY SEVEN CREDIT ARMING THEM
PEARL CONSIDERATION PROGRAMS
ARE CURRENTLY ESTIMATES REDUCE
THE AVERAGE DAILY ADULT
POPULATION- FINDING ADDITIONAL.
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO- UNFORTUNATELY
OUR POPULATION WAS ALSO WERE
CHAIRED BY THE REJECTION OF-
OUR INTAKE FROM COUNTY JAILS IN
MARCH DUE TO THE CODE THEN-
OUTBREAKS WE SUSPENDED INTAKE
FROM THE COUNTY JAILS. AND WE
SIMPLY BEGAN TO OPEN UP FOR IN
TANK- AT DIFFERENT MONTHS. AND
UNFORTUNATELY HAD TO CLOSE
AGAIN SO RIGHT NOW WE'VE BEEN
OPEN AND- FOR A SHORT TIME
BRINGING BACK OUR COUNTY AND
CHECK RIGHT NOW THERE'S ALMOST-
THERE'S A TEN THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED CAN DEMAND TAKEN THE
COUNTY JAILS. SO IN THE
INTEREST OF THE COUNTY JAILS
AND THOSE WHO CANNOT TRANSFER
TO CVC ARE- THIS STATE IS
REQUIRED TO REIMBURSE THE
COUNTIES FOR HOLDING NOT
POPULATION THERE'S A LOT OF
PRESSURE TO GET THOSE
POPULATION AND BUT WE ALSO HAVE
TO DO IT IN A SAFE MANNER. OR
WORK VERY VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
RECEIVERS OFFICE TO ACCOMPLISH
THIS- AND THE COUNTIES HAVE
BEEN SOMEWHAT PATIENT WITH
THAT- ANYWAY SOME. OF THE
BUDGET THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDED THE FUNDING OF
THIRTEEN POINT ONE. BILLION
DOLLARS FOR CDC ARE AT TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO THIS IS A
DECREASE OF APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED AND FOUR MILLION- TO
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT.
SOME HIGHLIGHTS FROM THAT FROM
THE BUDGET OTHERS ARE C. C. R-
COALBED DIRECT RESPONSE
EXPENDITURES THIS IS OBVIOUSLY
BECAUSE IT IS OUR TOP PRIORITY.
AND TO KEEP OUR STAFF AND
POPULATION SAFE IN ORDER TO
RESPOND TO CO THE AND MEDICAID
IT'S IMPACT CDC ARE INSISTING
H. U. S. WILL SPEND A BILLION
DOLLARS OUR PUBLIC RELIEF
BETWEEN TWENTY ONE. THIS
SPENDING INCLUDES TENTS AND
EQUIPMENT TENTS WAS TO
DECOMPRESS THE POPULATION- OR
ASSIST WITH TREATMENT SPACE-
FOR THE POPULATION OF THE
INSTITUTIONS. FOR THAT RENTALS
DEEP CLEANING OF THE
INSTITUTIONS PURCHASING IN A
PERSONAL. PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT.
I FOR IN AND STAFF AND FOR-
INMATES COULD HOW- AND MEDICAL
MEDICAL REGISTRIES TO AS WELL
AS A TIME AND OTHER CHIU. BOB
ALSO PLEASE TO ANNOUNCE THAT WE
ENDED OUR UTILIZATION OF- MOST
OF OUR- HELLO. TO PROFIT SEVEN
M. FOR. AND TRY REJECTION AND
AS A SIGNATURE ORDER TO. AND
FIVE THE COLLEGE. OF BARBER THE
STATE IN THE IN JUNE. TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND IMAGES
SIX CIGAR TERM SIX OF SEVEN OF
ARKANSAS COLLEGE BY OCTOBER.
TWENTY TWENTY. ABOUT REFLECTS
THE CALL OF IN STATE CONTRACT
FACILITY AND MAY TWENTY ONE.
FOR THE CLOSURE CONSISTENT WITH
THE BUDGET AND THE LEGISLATION
PASSED LAST SUMMER THE
DEPARTMENT PLANS TO CLOSE WITH
CASUAL INSTITUTE. BY SEPTEMBER
OF TWENTY ONE WE ARE ON TRACK
FOR THAT- SO CHECK. CHEATING
THIRTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THE GENERAL FUND AND
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TO. A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY POINT SIX MILLION
BEGINNING TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. DEMONSTRATE PLANS TO
CLOSE THE SECOND PRISON AND
TWENTY JUNE TWENTY THREE THAT
IS YET TO BE ANNOUNCED. NEW
OPPORTUNITIES ADMIT- OF ALL TE
EFFORTS OF RESPONDING TO THE
PANDEMIC I DO WANT TO NOTE SOME
OF THE PROPOSALS AND I'M
EXCITED ABOUT BECAUSE THEY
FOCUS ON REBUILDING CONTINUED
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS FOR
CARCERI TO POPULATION. AS WELL
AS INCREASED TRADE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR DEDICATED
STAFF AMONG OTHER THINGS THESE
INITIATIVES HELP SEPARATE
APARTMENT UP FOR A PASSED. OF
OUR LONG TERM. OF WORKSHOPS THE
CALIFORNIA. TECHNOLOGY FOR
STUDENTS PARTICIPATE IN
ACADEMIC PROGRAMS THIS BUDGET
INCLUDES TWENTY THREE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO
ENHANCE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING. EACH WILL PURCHASE
APPROXIMATELY. THIRTY EIGHT
HUNDRED LAPTOP COMPUTERS USED
COMPUTERS BY OUR ACADEMIC
PROGRAM TO INCLUDE BASIC ADULT
EDUCATION GVG COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. IN ADDITION WE HAVE
SEVERAL INSTITUTIONS I HAVE FOR
YOUR COLLEGE PROGRAMS AND WITH
THE RESET AND ANNOUNCEMENT OF
THE PELL GRANTS COMING BACK FOR
THE POPULATION I ANTICIPATE
FURTHER EXPANSION OF OUR
COLLEGE FOUR YEAR COLLEGE
PROGRAMS WITHIN OUR
INSTITUTIONS THE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THAT. I SAY YOU KNOW OUR
THAT ARE THEIR COLLEGE DEGREES
MANY OF THEM ARE HAVING TO DO A
TERM PAPER YOU HAVE WRITTEN
TERM PAPER I CAN'T IMAGINE
TRYING TO DO A HAMMER AND TERM
PAPER TWENTY TWENTY ONE- I EVEN
HAD THE LUXURY OF A WORD
PROCESSOR BACK IN MY DAY. SO
VERY LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT
AND CERTAINLY- REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT. OF PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES ABILITY.
THE VIRTUALISATION AND
CONSTRUCTION- IN ORDER TO HAVE.
A COMPUTER SYSTEM WE HAVE TO
HAVE A CLOSE TO OUTSIDE
INTERNET SO I HAVE TO BE A
CLOSED KIND OF SYSTEM- SO WE
NEED TO INCREASE OUR NETWORK
BANDWIDTH PRETTY THIS YEAR.
SECURE ONLINE PORTAL WHICH WILL
ALLOW STUDENTS TO ACCESS
CURRICULA- OUTSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM. IMPLEMENTATION OF
SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY TWO THE
TRANSGENDER RESPECT AGENCY AND
DIGNITY ACTRESS BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES FUNDING OF TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SENATE BACK
ONE THIRTY TWO. WHICH REQUIRES
THE C. R. TO HOWLS AND TO
CONDUCT PHYSICAL SEARCHES OF
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS.
ACCORDING TO THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY AND GENDER AND HOUSING
PREFERENCES CDCR WILL UPDATE
DATA REPOSITORIES WITH GENDER
IDENTIFYING MARKERS. PROCESS
HOUSING CHANGE REQUEST TRAIN
STAFF ON SAFE HOUSING PRACTICES
APPROPRIATE PRONOUN USAGE AND
PROPER SEARCH PROCEDURES WE'VE
ALREADY BEGUN TRANSFERRING
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE REQUESTED
IT FEDERLINE THEM WITH THEIR
ENTRANCE- THEIR GENDER IDENTITY-
AND AS OF THIS WEEK AS SOON AS
OF LAST WEEK WE HAVE REMOVED.
FOR TRANS GENDER FEMALES FROM
NOW INSTITUTIONS TO BE BALANCED
OF THOSE EVALUATION ARE ONGOING
AND EVERY DAY. CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER TRAINING AND JOB SALARY
PROGRAM THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
HAS PROPOSED FUNDING TWENTY ONE
POINT TWO MILLION TO IMPROVE
THE DEPARTMENT'S TRAINING.
INSTITUTION BASED. CUSTODY
STAFF THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES
THE FOLLOWING COMPONENTS
IMPLEMENTED A FOUR WEEK JOB
SHADOWING AND A NEW EMPLOYEE
ORIENTATION PROGRAM FROM THE
GRADUATING CADETS. AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL IN SERVICE TRAINING
SERGEANT POSITIONS TO MEET THE
INCREASED WORKLOAD RE PURPOSING
OF THE FORMER NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY IN
STOCKTON AND SHOWING THEM VANCE
TRAINING FACILITY THAT WILL
INCLUDE REALITY BASED EXERCISES
PROBLEM SOLVING. LEARNING
COMPONENTS AND INCREASE OPPOSED
STAFFING TO PRE ORDER NEXT. I
WILL SAY THAT WHENEVER WE LOOK
AT ANY MAJOR INCIDENTS WITHIN
OUR FACILITY SAID OFTENTIMES
IT'S THE YOUNG BRAND NEW STAFF
THAT YOU KNOW SOMETIMES DON'T
KNOW HOW TO HANDLE THE
SITUATION SO DESPERATE REMOVED.
WHAT IS THE BUSINESS S. IT
INCREASED. MENU OPTIONS IS A
PER PART OF MINE- IN HOUSE BEEN
TO APPROACH A HELL MAY CHORE
POPULAR. MORE RELIANT FRESH PER
PRO AND OTHER HEALTHY FOODS.
THE BUDGET PROVIDES SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION. ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THE
EFFORTS CONSISTENT WITH THE
FEDERAL DIETARY CHANGES THAT
WE'VE EXPERIENCED OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN THOUSAND TWENTY TRYING
TO GET UP TO SPEED- WITH THOSE
WITH THOSE OPTIONS- I KNOW YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU LOOK AT YOU KNOW
ARE COSTING FOR HER AND-
INMATES AT IS ASKING US TO
CHANGE FROM. THREE DOLLARS AN
EIGHTEEN CENTS PER DAY PER
INMATE TO THIRTY DOLLARS AND
FORTY CENTS PER DAY PER INMATE-
I REALIZE THAT ADDS UP BUT I DO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT COMPONENT
FOR THE LONG TERM HEALTH OF
BARTENDERS- LESS SUGAR LOCALS
PROCESS. WITH LESS SODIUM THOSE
TYPE OF THINGS REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT THAT. OUR ENERGY FROM
FINALLY THE BUDGET PLAN.
INCLUDES ONE H. MILLION AND
FUNDING MAINTAIN ACCESS BANNER
ACTS SYSTEM TO BLOCK THE VIEW
OF CONTRABAND WITHIN OUR CHIU.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A VERY HIGHLY.
OF REVIEW OF SOME OF THE BEST A
POP POP IS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY JUST TO YOU TODAY
MYSELF AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE GAME WITH YOUR THE NEXT FOR
MONTHS THE HEARING PROCESS WELL
CERTAINLY I THINK CONSTRUCTION.
THANK YOU REFER OPEN IT UP TO.
THIS DEPARTMENT FINANCE OR L.
A. ILL HAVE ANY COMMENTS MAKE.
YOU CAN. THOUSAND HE WOULD
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU. FOR THE LAKERS MAR TH
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
NO COMMENTS THIS TIME. HEY
THANK YOU HAVE A THE PRESENT I
DO HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS AND
CONCERN IN SOME OF THE MEMBERS
ALSO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS- I'M
GONNA START OFF BY ASKING WE'VE
YOU MENTIONED THAT THERE'S
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND FEWER
PEOPLE IN PRISON NOW THAN IN
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY. AND THIRTY
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
SAVINGS THAT WE HAVE SEEN WITH
THE DECREASE IN THE PRISON
POPULATION AND HOW THE
DEPARTMENT IS REDIRECTING THE
SAVINGS- AND WHAT KIND OF ON
GOING SAVINGS ARE YOU
ANTICIPATING. YEAH THIS IS A
ERIC SWANSON I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF US JUST GO SERVICES
AT CDC- WE HAVE. THE SAVING
ASSOCIATE WITH HER- POPPING
DECREASE. I'M A LOT OF THE
SAVINGS THAT WE HAVE ACHIEVED
WE'VE HAD TO. READER TO CALL IT
UP AGAIN EFFORTS. ARE SO FAR BY
IS A LOW IS CERTAIN. ALISON IN
THE IN HER INITIAL CALL. HOW
SOME OF THE SAVINGS THAT WE
MANAGE TO. OKAY ON TO THE NEXT
OF MEDICAID EFFORTS THAT WE ARE.
A INSIDE THE PRISONS. THAT THE
ALL THE SAVINGS TO LETTER DO WE
A BREAK. AND DO WE HAVE
ANTICIPATION FOR OF DOWN THE
ROAD HELLO FABIAN'S MIGHT BE
USED. YEAH I CAN PROVIDE YOU IF
YOU WANT I CAN PROVIDE YOUR
STAFF WITH THE BREAKDOWN OF- OF
THE SAVINGS THAT WE ARE
ANTICIPATED TO RECEIVE FROM
THOSE THAT WE- ARE REDIRECTED
TO COPE WITH MEDICATION. THAT
WOULD BE APPRECIATED I HOPE AS
WE CONTINUE THE WORK WE LOOK AT
THE PRESENT MOMENT. THAT WE
DEFINITELY HAVE BEING
CHALLENGED WITH AND I KNOW THAT
THAT REALITY CHANGES ON US
EVERY DAY- BUT I HOPE THAT
WOULD ALSO START THINKING LONG
TERM AND PLANNING AHEAD- ALONG
THE WAY. I WITH THE SAME WITH
THE SAME A LINE OF QUESTIONING
WE HAVE SEEN A DECREASE IN THE
PRISON POPULATION- AND DOWN 20%
CAN YOU GIVE US AN UPDATE. ON
WHAT YOU ARE EXPECTING FOR
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE TO BE
RELEASED EACH MONTH. DUE TO THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER AS WE CONTINUE.
SO OURONGOING EFFORTS- AND I
DID FAILED TO MENTION IN MY
OPENING COMMENTS ABOUT OUR
TWELVE WEEK PASTA PROGRAMMING
CREDIT THAT WAS AFFORDED TO ALL
OFFENDERS THAT WERE NOT. A LOT
FOR CONTEMPT. WE ARE CONTINUING
WITH OUR SIX MONTH TO RELEASE
ONGOING. AND WE ALSO CONTINUE-
WE'RE LOOKING AT SOME
INDETERMINATE LEAST SENTENCED
OFFENDERS LOOKING AT THAT
PROCESS TO SEE IF THERE WAS ANY
RELIEF. EVERY ALL THE HIGH RISK
MEDICAL CASES- THE MAJORITY OF
THE HIGHER RISK MEDICAL CASES
THE MISTER DS AND I BOTH DID
FOR I DETERMINE THE STEPS THAT
WE- DIFFERENT THAT ENDED. SO WE
ARE IN AT FAST- AS FAR AS
ESTIMATES. ESTIMATES I WOULD
SAY I WOULD HAVE TO GET YOU
SPECIFIC NUMBERS AS IT RELATES
TO THAT. I MEAN I CAN TELL YOU
HOW MANY WE HAVE GOING ON ON
ANY GIVEN MONTH. BUT INTEL WE-
CLEAR THE BACK. OF OUR INTAKE I
THINK IT'S GOOD IT'S TO BE HARD
FOR TO WITHOUT SHORT OF
RESEARCH TO. SHOULD BE TO
PROVIDE YOU THAT. FOR SO I
GUESS THAT'S AS WITH READING
ABOUT PLANNING ONE TO RELEASE-
THESE INDIVIDUALS MAKING SURE
THAT THEY'RE SUFFICIENT RE
ENTRY SUPPORT ON THE BACKEND. I
THINK SOME OF THOSE NUMBERS ARE
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE PLANNING
BOTH PIECES SO THAT WE CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL LONG TERM. SO I
THINK AT WE WOULD APPRECIATE
SOME OF THOSE NUMBERS ARE TO BE
BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION IN THE
NEAR FUTURE. THANK YOU AND I
WILL SAY THAT- ALL THEIR FIRST
RELEASES DID NOT NECESSARILY
COME WITH A COUPLE HUNDRED OF
SUPPORT HOWEVER THE JULY FIRST
THROUGH PRESIDENT RELEASES ARE
RECEIVING SUPPORT THROUGH OUR
STOP PROGRAMS THROUGH OUR
PAROLE DIVISION- AS WELL AS
SOME FUNDING FROM A GRANT FROM
THE SEC WE RECEIVED A FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT FOR LATCH
AND THOSE I WILL SAY THAT. WE
HAVE A LOT OF OFFENDERS IN
THOSE BEDS AND I THINK IT'S
MADE OF A MARKET DIFFERENCE
AND- FIVE HOPEFULLY WILL TAKE A
MARKET DIFFERENCE IN THE
OUTCOMES. OF A DEFENDER SO
LEAST THEY HAVE A NICE LANDING
SPOT OF VERSATA IS BEING- ALBUM
SHOOT DIRECTLY OUT TO THE
COMMUNITY WITH NO HOUSING
SUPPORT. SO CITED A THAT THE
BEEN A TO- OFFENDERS WITH THAT
OFFER. CAN TWENTY EIGHTH IN
JULY WE DON'T HAVE ANY SERVICES
THE REAR FOR THE IN THE FROM
END ARE WE TALKING ABOUT IN
EVERY TRACKING THEM NOW OR THE
TH WE'VE- LOST TRACK OF THEM
COMPLETELY. NO AND I'M SORRY
OKAY SO INITIAL WE SHOULD MAKE
IT. FOR ALL- THEY WERE ABOUT
TWENTY HUNDRED OFFENDERS
RELEASED EARLY. DOES HI THIS SO
ARE WORLD IF THEY FOR PAROLE
THEY WERE A TO GO TO PRO. IF
NOT THEY HAVE THE WORK FOR POST
RELEASE COMMUNITY SUPERVISION
THEY HAVE TO GO INTO ONE OF
THEIR PROGRAMS THAT ARE RUN BY
THE COUNTIES IN JULY WE STOOD
UP THE- THE SEC MONIES WE
DIDN'T CARE WHERE THEY WERE
GOING WHETHER THEY WERE GOING
TO PAROLE SUPERVISION OUR
COMMUNITY SUPERVISION THEY WERE
ABLE TO ACCESS THIS PROGRAM SO
IT REALLY BROKE DOWN ALL THE
BARRIERS FOR PEOPLE ACCESSING
PROGRAMS THAT I REALLY DO THINK
THAT THAT'S MADE OF
MODIFICATION. EARTH AND WE HAVE
AND I HAVE EXACT NUMBERS OF
FISH WHICH IS TO PAY THOSE
PROGRAMS TODAY I'M ACTUALLY
TRYING TO FIND IT NOW. SO- I
HAVE MORE QUESTIONS BUT I'M
GONNA OPEN IT UP TO MY
COLLEAGUES BEFORE I AM. THAT'S
MY QUESTIONS. MR STONE. THANK
YOU JUST. TRYING TO MAKE SOME
SENSE OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN GIVEN
AND I REALIZE THIS IS THIS IS
TOP LEVEL BUT STAYING WITH THE
TOP LEVEL ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE SAYING AND I THINK
WE DEFINITELY NEED TO SEE. THE
DOLLARS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
COVERT RESPONSE BECAUSE- WE'VE
BEEN TRACKING YEAR TO YEAR. THE
EXPECTED SAVINGS OUT OF THE
BUDGET BECAUSE OF THE REDUCTION
IN THE POPULATION. AND WE'RE
SEEING ADDITIONAL DEBT
REDUCTION OF POPULATION BECAUSE
OF CODE BUT ALSO ADDITIONAL
EXPENSES SO FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO TRACK YEAR TO YEAR AND
UNDERSTAND HOW. WHAT THE TRENDS
ARE AND WHETHER WE'RE ON TRACK
WE NEED TO SEE THOSE
EXTRAORDINARY EXPENSES. PULLED
OUT. WHICH IS LOOKING AT THE
DATA THAT YOU GAVE US. GOING
THAT NINETEEN TWENTY YEAR TO
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE YEAR TO
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO YEAR
WHICH IS THE PROPOSED BUDGET.
FROM. 201-922-2020 ONE BUDGET
WENT UP. BUDGET POSITIONS WHAT
UP AND THE PRISON POPULATION
STAYED ABOUT THE SAME FLIGHT
DROP BUT LOOKING FOR FROM
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ENACTED TO
THE PROPOSED BUDGET WE'RE
SEEING THE TOTAL BUDGET. NOT
REALLY CHANGING THAT MUCH BUT A
SEVENTY DAY BUT THE POPULATION
IS 77% OF WHAT IT HAD BEEN. AND
THE BUDGET POSITIONS OR OR 95%
OF WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN. SO I
THINK WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL FOR
US TO UNDERSTAND. IF WE'RE
GOING TO BECAUSE AND A LOT OF
YOUR COSTS ARE ARE TAKEN UP IN
PERSONNEL COSTS. SO AS WE'RE
TRACKING THE REDUCTION IN. THE
POPULATION OF PEOPLE ARE OF
COURSE RATED. WE NEED TO HAVE A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
THAT IMPACT IS WITH THE BUDGET
POSITIONS SO THAT WE CAN
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE SAVINGS IS.
BECAUSE WE'RE SEEING A REAL
REDUCTION IN THE PUT THE OF THE
POPULATION BUT NOT A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN THE
BUDGET POSITIONS IT'S REALLY
HARD TO UNDERSTAND HOW WE'RE
GETTING THE EFFICIENCIES THAT
WE'RE- EXPECTING TO GET OUT OF
IT AND THEN ADD ON TOP OF THAT
OF COURSE THE PRISON CLOSURES
WHICH WE'RE GONNA SEE. ADDED AT
A DIFFERENT HEARING. DOES ALL
TAKEN TOGETHER OUR LITTLE
LITTLE DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND
WITH THAT THE LIMITED
INFORMATION THAT WE'VE- HAD
HERE TODAY SO THAT'S WHAT I'M
REQUESTING IS TO SEE. IF WE CAN
GET THE PUBLIC RESPONSE MONEY
TAKEN OUT OF THIS SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE SOME SENSE OF IT AND
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE WHAT
THE PLAN IS FOR MANAGING THE
BUDGET POSITION SO THAT WE CAN
SEE HOW THE DROP AS WE'RE
CLOSING PRISONS AND AS- THE
AVERAGE DAILY POPULATION IS THE
DAILY POPULATION IS. WHERE THE
OVERALL PRISON POPULATION IS
DROPPING IN CALIFORNIA WE NEED
TO SEE WHAT THOSE SAVINGS ARE.
GOING TO LOOK LIKE OVER TIME.
HI THIS IS ALLISON FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THEY JUST
WANT IT I CAME IN HERE WITH A
BIT OF A CLARIFYING POINTS SO
WE HAVE CALCULATED AS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY EIGHT POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN POPULATION
SAVINGS THAT WOULD IT BE
REDIRECTED TO COVERT RESPONSE.
UNDER SECRETARY MENTIONS THAT
WE'RE ESTIMATING BETWEEN
NINETEEN TWENTY AND CURRENT
YEAR AND TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. AND EXPENDITURES OF ABOUT
ONE BILLION DOLLARS I'M INTO
THE TO SIXTY EIGHT POINT FIVE
IN THE CURRENT YEAR WHICH IS
ASSOCIATED WITH POPULATION
SAVINGS WOULD BE REDIRECTED TO
COPE IN RESPONSE WHICH STILL
LEAVES A GAP I'M WHICH WERE
STILL GOING TO. WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION STILL GOING TO
BE LOOKING AT IN ADDITION TO
TRYING TO MAXIMIZE FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT'S AVAILABLE I'M
BUT I JUST WANTED TO CHIME IN
WITH THAT FIGURE IN CASE IT'S
HELPFUL TO YOU IT IS IT IS
GOING OUT- AND CALLED OUT. AND
IN THE BUDGET DOCUMENTS BUT
HAPPY. TO PROVIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION FROM
THERE. WELL IF IT IS BUT I'M
ALSO LOOK. AT THE OVERALL N.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS IT IS A
VERY SMALL DROP IN THE IN THE
BUDGET AND PART OF THAT AS WAS
EXPLAINED IS BECAUSE OF THE
COVERT EXPENSES. SO IF WHICH I
GUESS IS OKAY IF WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE THAT AND THEN. RECOGNIZE
WHAT THE SPECIFIC COVERED
EXPENSES ARE IN DEFICIT THAT
OUT. OKAY I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING.
INFORMATION THAT WE CAN TRACK
AND SEE SO THAT WE CAN SEPARATE
THE COVERT RESPONSE. N. IN
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE REDUCTIONS
ARE EVEN WHEN WE'RE TAKING A
LOOK AT THESE TOP LEVEL
POSITIONS OR THESE TOP LEVEL
KIND OF SUMMARIES. BECAUSE YOU
JUST LOOK AT. THE DAILY
POPULATION AND ITS DROP AND
THEN YOU LOOK AT THE BUDGET
POSITIONS AND THE TOTAL BUDGET
THEY'RE NOT DROPPING AT THE
SAME LEVEL. THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY GOING TO AND THAT'S
FINE BUT FOR US TO UNDERSTAND
HOW ALL OF THOSE RELATE
TOGETHER. I THINK THAT WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL TO BE ABLE TO SEE.
WHAT MAKE SURE THAT WHAT WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT AND THEN WE
CAN DIFFERENTIATE THE COVERT
EXPENSES. OVER THE THIS YEAR.
BUDGET HERE LAST YEAR WHENEVER
THOSE ARE ARE RELATED AND
UNDERSTAND HOW THOSE ARE BEING
IMPACTED WHERE WERE MAKING
THOSE INVESTMENTS WHERE THOSE-
DO WHERE THOSE ARE NEGATIVELY
AFFECTING THE SAVINGS WE WOULD
OTHERWISE EXPECT. JUST THAT WE
HAVE A CLEAR PICTURE OF KIND OF
THE TRACK THAT WERE ON. THANK
YOU AND I DID SOME QUICK MATH
AND WE HAVE AN OVER 20% DECLINE
IN THE PRISON POPULATION BUT-
ABOUT 4% DECLINE IN THE PROJECT
THE POSITIONS THAT WE HAVE HERE
YEAH- AND SO THE LEAST THAT
DISCREPANCY I THINK WE NEED TO
BE EXPLAINED TO US- MAYBE
THERE'S VALIDITY TO. TO OF
NUMBERS I AND THEN I WOULD GO
BACK TO THE SEPARATION IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE CAN LOOK AT
THE MOMENT RIGHT NOW BUT WE'RE
NOT ALWAYS GOING TO BE IN THIS
MOMENT AND WE WANT TO BE
PLANNING LONG TERM AS WELL. FOR
THOSE QUESTIONS MR STONE. WE
HAVE SOMEONE ELSE SOMEONE SPEAK.
MISTER JONES SAWYER. BUT IT
THANK YOU SECRETARY ALISON- A.
N. THE OTHER TYPICAL ABOUT THE
20% DECREASE. IS ALREADY BEEN
ADDRESSED AND I THINK WE REALLY
DO NEED SOME CLARIFICATION ON
AND I'M JUST ECHOING WHAT MIGHT
TO COLLEAGUE SAID IF SAID
EARLIER OPTIMA MY FIRST CONCERN
I JUST A COUPLE QUESTIONS MY
FIRST CONCERN IS. YES WE'VE
RELEASED. INDIVIDUALS OUT AND I
GUESS THERE'S A 20% DECREASE IN
THE NUMBER RECENT ABOUT-COMMUNITY SUPERVISION NON NON
NON EARLY RELEASE HIGH RISK
MEDICAL REVIEW RELEASED COURT
REFER ORIGINALLY SET UP PROP
FIFTY SEVEN EARLY RELEASE
CREDITS. AND REDUCTION OF
INMATES COMING IN FROM THE
COUNTY JAILS ABOUT TEN THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED- AS WHY WE REDUCE
OUR OUR POPULATION. WHEN IT
COMES TO COMMUNITY SERVICE
SUPERVISION AND OTHER PROGRAMS
YOU MENTION SOME OF PAROLE I DO
WE EVER DO. ANY ASSESSMENT OF
HOW BECTIVE AND PATIENT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE WHETHER THEY'RE
NCDC ARE. ARE OUT. IN TWO
NONPROFITS AND INTO THE
COMMUNITY DO WE DO HAVE A SENSE
OF HOW EFFECTIVE THEY ARE OR WE
KIND OF A- A WIDGET SEN. BUT WE
REALLY DON'T CARE WHAT HAPPENS
SHOULD WHICH IS COMING OUT WE
JUST WE JUST PLUGGING PEOPLE
INTO PROGRAMS AND WE NEVER
REALLY DETERMINE THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS. AND EFFICIENCY.
THANK YOU I- WE DO HAVE SOME OF
THE RESEARCH BEING CONDUCTED ON
OUR PROGRAMS WE ASK FOR ALL
OVER PROGRAM PROVIDERS TO BE
EVIDENCE BASED BASED ON THE
QUEUE- CRITERIA FOR. EVALUATING
PROGRAMS SO THERE IS A
VALUATION WE ALSO CONTINUE WITH
OUR RECIDIVISM REVIEWS. OF OUR
OVERALL RECIDIVISM I HAVE ASKED
IN PARTICULAR TO HAVE DATA. AS
IT RELATES TO THIS- ARE. LET'S
CALL HAVEN'T ARE SEE HOW
EFFORTS ARE TO BE ABLE TO TRY
THOSE OFFENDERS TO SEE IF WE
ACTUALLY DID PROVE THAT THAT.
SOFT LANDING SPOT OF BREAKING
DOWN ALL THOSE BARRIERS SINCE
BEEN HELPFUL ONE OF THE
CRITERIA CHANGES THAT WE MADE
IN THAT PROGRAM IS OFTENTIMES
OFFENDERS FEEL LIKE THEY CAN GO
HOME TO THEIR GRANDMA'S HOUSE
OUR MOM'S HOUSE- AND
UNFORTUNATELY TWO WEEKS LATER
THEY- THAT SITUATION IS
CHANGING THEY HAVE THEY NO
LONGER HAVE HOUSING OPTIONS. SO
THIS PROGRAM IS FLEXIBLE ENOUGH
THAT ALL IT IS HEY IT'S A PHONE
CALL TO THE PAROLE AGENT HEY I
NEED A PLACE TO GO AND WE'RE
ABLE TO HOUSE THEM- VERY
RAPIDLY. AND SO I WE DO HAVE
OUR- AN EMPLOYEE FROM DR HAVE A
ON THE PHONE COULD MAYBE STILL
MORE SO. ABOUT SOME OF THE
RESEARCH- OPPORTUNITIES. SO I
ONLY HAVE A FEW MORE MINUTES
LET ME DO IT THIS WAY MAYBE AND
GET BACK UP TO. HER QUESTIONS
AND THE REASON THAT LAST WAS SO
IMPORTANT IS BECAUSE- THE CHAIR
ASSEMBLY BUDGET IS REALLY
REALLY HARD WHEN IT COMES TO
GETTING NEW PROGRAMS IF YOU CAN
PROVE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF YOUR
PROGRAMS- YOU CAN YOU CAN
REALLY DO WELL WHEN IT COMES TO
THE BUDGET AND HOW WE PROGRAM
FUNDING AND SO I WOULD URGE YOU
TO GET INVOLVED IN THAT. AND
THEN. ARE WE GETTING PREPARED
YOU THIS IS PROBABLY A GLOBAL
QUESTION. ARE WE GETTIN
PREPARED FOR VACCINATION. THAT
IS THE NEXT TRUMP STEROID YES
WE'RE DOING. ALL WE CAN TO
IDENTIFY AND WE HAVE DONE. THAT
GOOD JOB FROM WHAT I CAN SEE
BUT EVENTUALLY. EVENTUALLY VERY
SOON WE SHOULD HAVE
VACCINATIONS AND IS CDC ARE
READY FOR THAT YOU CAN ANSWER
THAT LATER. AND THEN YOU
MENTIONED VIDEO VISUALIZATION
COMPUTER SYSTEM. WHAT ABOUT
CAMMISH. ARE YOU PUT YOU PUT
ANY MONEY IN THE BUDGET SO THAT
EVERY PERSON CDCR- HAS SOME
TYPE OF CAMERA SO WE CAN SEE
FINALLY SEE WHAT'S GOING ON. IN
OUR PRISONS AND WE CAN MAKE
EFFECTIVE DECISIONS ON WHAT CAN
AND CAN'T BE DONE. AND THE
VEXING QUESTION AS PART OF
ISSUE TO SOME AND A HALF OF THE
HOLD UP ON THAT- DO YOU WANT
TO. RESPOND ABOUT THE CAMERAS
AND THEY WILL WANT TO MISTER
LACKING. ABSOLUTELY AS- AS THIS
COMMITTEE KNOWS WE'VE COME BACK
AND FORTH OVER THE YEARS
REQUESTING DIFFERENT- REQUEST
FOR CAMERAS THERE IS. AN R.
ARMSTRONG ORDER THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL REQUEST FOR CAMERAS.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED A
PILOT F. R. G. D. WHICH IS AN
OPERATING RICHARD J. DONAHUE-
INSTITUTION SAID THE ECHO. OF
WE'VE IMPLEMENTED BODY CAMERAS
AND WE PLAN TO HAVE A FULL
INSTALLATION OF FIXED CAMERAS
IN APRIL. WE CERTAINLY WELCOME
CAMERA BUT THEY'RE QUITE COSTLY
CAMERAS CAMERAS ARE ABOUT ONE
POINT SIX MILLION ON AVERAGE
AND OUR- FIXED CAMERA SYSTEMS
ARE. A SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
PER INSTITUTION UNDERSTAND OUR
INSTITUTIONS. IN SIZE- AND SO
THAT REALLY THE STUFF OF THE
FOOTPRINT TO- AS WELL AS A
NUMBER OF STAFF. JEFF CHASE THE
COSTING OF CAMERAS COULD YOU.
COULD YOU GET ME GET THIS
COMMITTEE. THAT QUOTE US I
THINK I COULD GET A BETTER
QUOTE BUT THAT'S NEITHER HERE
NOR THERE PLUS. IT'S JUST
IMPORTANT THAT. THE LIFE AND
SAFETY OF INMATES SHOULD NOT BE
BASED ON HOW MUCH IT COSTS WE
SHOULD WE SHOULD LOOK ABOVE AND
BEYOND THAT. BUT WE WILL MAKE
NOTED THAT HE GET THAT
INFORMATION TO US IN THE FUTURE
IN THE MEANTIME I'M GOING TO
MOVE ON TO WHAT THE VICE CHAIR.
THE COMMITTEE MR LACKEY LEFT
THE COUPLE QUESTIONS AS WELL.
YEAH MY QUESTION IS ACTUALLY
QUITE SIMPLE HAS TO DO WITH
THE- THE WORKERS COMP. COSTS AS
THEY RELATE TO- CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS I IF I'M CORRECT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT FIFTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS. APPROXIMATELY IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET.
FOR WORKERS COMP RELATED TO
THIS CALL WITH THE SITUATION- I
AM I CORRECT ON THAT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THIS IS AN EFFORT
SPONSORED AGAIN DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF THE OFFICE OF FISCAL
SERVICES WE DO HAVE A PROPOSAL
IN THE- GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
THAT'S ATTACHED TO. I THINK
IT'S AB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE WHICH
WAS A BILL THAT PASSED ON. LAST
YEAR THEY CHANGES THE
PRESUMPTION FOR. ATTACHED TO
PUT. IN THE WORK PLACE- THIS
ONE WHAT AND WHERE WE HAVE TO
ADMIT THAT THERE IS A- GREAT
DEAL OF UNKNOWN BECAUSE WE'RE
KIND OF- IS YOU KNOW WE'RE KIND
OF GOING THROUGH COMING IN REAL
TIME. LEAVING SOME CUSTOMERS
BASED ON. WHAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED SO FAR BUT- PART OF
THE PROPOSAL IS THAT. IF OUR
COSTS COME INTO HARD IF OUR
GUESS IS WRONG. THEN WE HOW THE
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
ALLOW US. TO TO. USE THE
FUNDING THAT'S ATTACHED TO THE
PROPOSAL WOULDN'T GO BACK TO
THE GENERAL FUND. BUT WITH
DEDICATION TO THE LEGISLATURE-
BUT BASS HAS BEEN WE'VE
EXPERIENCED- SOMETIMES YOU KNOW
OUR EMPLOYEES ARE THE FRONT
LINE AND THEY ARE VERY
SUSCEPTIBLE TO. TO COPE IT IS
REQUIRED EXPERIENCED WE DO
EXPECT TO INCUR SOME.
SIGNIFICANT COSTS IN THE COMING
YEARS. HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS
UR HERE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
DECLARE THEIR SPEED ONE DOLLAR.
AND INCLUDED IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO THEY IS NINE NINE
MILLION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND ARE SOME VARYING
AMOUNTS IN THE OUT YEARS. AND
IT'S NOT ONGOING FUNDING IT IS
YEAH IT EXTENDS THREE TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE AND BUT IT IS
IN RECOGNITION OF THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE LEGISLATION.
OKAY AND JUST PROGRESS I THINK
OF SENATE BILL ELEVEN FIFTY
NINE BUT YEAH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE INFO. THANK YOU
AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
HEARING ON MARCH FIRST WHERE WE
WILL BE. LOOKING AT ISSUES OF
CAMERAS AND WORKERS COMP SO.
MAYBE BY THEN- YOU CAN GET SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION SO WE
CAN BE A LITTLE LESS UNKNOWN.
CATEGORY IF WE DON'T HAVE ANY
AT WILL HAVE MISTER CHANG CLOSE
THE FACT THAT THIS PANEL. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THIS IS
WITH. GREAT TO THINK IT'S A
WONDERFUL FIRST. THE KICK OFF
FOR YOUR TENURE- OF MADAM
SECRETARY WHILE. PUSHING YOUR
YOUR PRESENCE TODAY AND JUST
HAD A JUST A COUPLE QUESTIONS
FOR. THE SECRETARY LAW
DEPARTMENT FINANCE I JUST GOING
BACK TO- ON. MISTER STONES LINE
OF QUESTIONING. WE SEE THAT
EVEN. AS THE- YOU KNOW WE WERE
LOSING. TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
POSITIONS AND- WE'RE LOSING
TWENTY. SEVEN THOUSAND INMATES.
THE BUDGET HAS BARELY GONE DOWN
SO- BASED ON YOUR PROJECTIONS
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO START
SEEING. ON SORT OF MUCH MORE
SIGNIFICANT DECREASES. IN THE
DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET. EVEN.
THIRTEEN THIS IS ERIC SWANSON
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF FISCAL
SERVICES BOB HEARD OF THE I
THINK THERE ARE- I CAN ANSWER
THE QUESTION KIND OF IN TWO
DIFFERENT WAYS THE FIRST TURN.
WAY IS THE TIME. OUR LONG TERM
REDUCTION PLAN FOR CDC ARE
RELATED TO POPULATION WAS TO
CUT- CONTRACT BASED FACILITY
ARE YOU SOME CONTRACTORS
FACILITIES FIRST. WE ARE
STARTING NOW TO GET INTO IS YOU
KNOW THIS LAST BUDGET HAS US
CLOSING DVI AND THEN WHAT IS
STILL PRESENT IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE OF THE POSITION
REDUCTIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT- WILL START- WILL START
GETTING HIGHER- BUT THAT WAS
PART OF OUR REGIONAL APPROACH
TO- GETTING US LESS RELIANT ON
OUR- OUT OF STATE PRISONS IN
ALABAMA AND OTHER PLACES. AND-
SO THAT WE CAN CUT THOSE FIRST
I THINK THE SECOND THING. THAT
WE SHOULD MENTION IS THAT- OPEN
ITSELF IS A FAST MOVING SO. WE
DID NOT. PREDICT BE PART
DECREASED WE EXPERIENCED NOW.
AND- IT CORRECT HERE WHILE
REDUCING THE PAST YEAR LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET AXLE. EVENTUALLY
I THINK AS WE GET MORE DATA WE
WILL BE ABLE TO- FEDERAL LINE-
THOSE TWO CATEGORIES OF DATA.
IN ADDITION TO THAT- I WILL SAY
THAT DUE TO CALL THAT A SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS YOU
HAVE TO SPREAD OUT OUR
BLUEPRINT WHAT WE COULD TO
CONSOLIDATE HOUSING UNITS THAT
WE WOULD TYPICALLY BE ABLE TO
CONSOLIDATE- WHEN OUR
POPULATION IS LOWER. BUT DUE TO
COLD AND WE HAD A DARK
SPECIALLY ARE OPEN DORMS WE
HAVE TO MAINTAIN SIX OF THE
DISTANCE AND SO WORRIED WE HAVE
A LARGER PHYSICAL FOOTPRINT.
AND YOU DON'T START SEEING
SAVINGS UNTIL YOU'RE ABLE TO
REDUCE THE STAFFING. CHECK FOR
WE CAN GET LET'S SAY- SO IT'S
ALSO COMPLICATING FACTOR. SO I
THINK WE'RE CLOSE IT IS OVER I
THINK YOU'LL YOU'LL START
SEEING SOME. SIGNIFICANT
SAVINGS THAT THAT EVERYBODY IS
ANXIOUS TO SEE BUT. PLEASE KEEP
IN MIND THAT WE STILL HAVE. YOU
KNOW NEARLY ALLOW THOUSAND IN
THE ACCOUNT JAILS HAVE TO IN
AND WE HAVE TO PAY THOSE X. TO
COUNT- INS IN THANK YOU FOR
HOUSING IN OUR OFFENDERS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU KNOW OF WILL BE
UNDERSTOOD- SO I GUESS THE
GOING YOUR YOUR POINT SO WHEN
COLD FOOD IS NOT GOOD FOR THE
ME JUST REPHRASE THE QUESTION
SO WHEN IT'S COLD IT IS OVER.
WHAT TYPE OF DROP IN
EXPENDITURE WOULD YOU
ANTICIPATE. HI ALEX CAN DO IT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I THINK JUST A COUPLE OF THINGS
THE FIRST IS. ON THE BUDGET
DOES REFLECT SAVINGS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE CLOSURE OF DVI. I MEAN
THAT'S NINETY FOUR C. NINETY
FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION I'M IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND ONE
TWENTY SIX POINT FOUR MILLION
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. AND
AGAIN THAT'S NOT THAT IS REALLY
WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A LOT
OF VERY DIRECT THE BEAMS COME
BECAUSE THE CLOSER CLICKS YOU
BE CLOSURE OF THE PRISON IS
REALLY IN RECOGNITION OF THEIR
DECLINING PRISON POPULATION.
AND THEN THERE WILL BE OTHER
ADJUSTMENTS THAT HAPPENED ON
THE NATURAL DETERRENTS THAT ARE
EXCUSE ME TIED TO YOU DIRECTLY
TO THE POPULATION IN CITIES YOU
ARE SO THOSE WOULD. COME ON THE
NATURAL BUT I THINK WHAT WE
WOULD SAY IN THE NEAR TERM IS
IT'S NOT THAT. I'M AND A LOT OF
WHAT YOU'LL SEE IN TERMS OF
THAT THAT POPULATION SAVINGS OR
SAVINGS THAT'S- RESULTING FROM
THE REDUCTION IN POPULATIONS IS
CAPTURED IN THE PRISON
CLOSURES. AND WE WOULD
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
CLOSE AN ADDITIONAL AND PRISON
WHICH WOULD COME FORWARD IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND SO
THAT WOULD AGAIN KIND OF. TIME
I'M CREATE ADDITIONAL SAVINGS
THAT WOULD THAT WOULD BE
REALIZED OVER THAT TIME I
THINK. THIS IS A WOULD BE ABLE
TO SHARE WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AS WELL. AND SO IS IT FAIR TO
ASSUME THAT WHEN THAT SECOND
FACILITY IS ANNOUNCED AND- SET
FOR CLOSURE WILL GET
APPROXIMATELY ABOUT THE SAME.
AMOUNT OF COST SAVINGS ROUGHLY.
IDON'T KNOW IF THAT'S- I MEAN
CERTAINLY BY OF THE ON. THAT'S
BUT I THINK THAT'S GOING TO. ON
A NUMBER OF. OPEN QUESTIONS
THIS TIME. NOTHING I CAN SHARE.
CERTAINLY THAT IN FOR. WOULD BE
A- IN THE- TO. FORWARD WHY IS
IT WHEN. EVEN PLAN ANNOUNCED
THE NEXT. I'M NOT ABLE TO SHARE
IT THIS TIME CERTAINLY HAPPY
TED TIP- FOLLOW UP I KNOW THAT
I. DID YEAH. ANNOUNCEMENT IS
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE THAT
WOULD WOULD THAT WOULD BE WHEN
WE BRING THE PROPOSAL FORWARD.
I'M NOT ABLE TO HEAR ANYTHING
AS TO TIMING. THE TRUST GO BACK
TO THE CONTRACT BASED
FACILITIES THE- THE PARTY WAS
TALKING ABOUT I JUST WANNA
CLARIFY. I KNOW WE WERE VERY
MUCH IN FAVOR OF CLOSING OUT-
CONTRACTS HOWEVER I THINK THERE
WERE. SOME CONTRACT THE
FACILITIES THAT WE THOUGHT IT
MADE SENSE TO CONTINUE. SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY WERE IN
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER SHAPE.
THAN THAN MANY OF OUR
FACILITIES AND SO WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE SAME AMOUNT OF
DEFERRED. MAINTENANCE FOR THOSE
FACILITIES AS WE DO FOR. OTHER
FACILITIES INACTION FROM START
TO THE CONTRACT WITH WHICH WE
HAVE NO DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BECAUSE WE DON'T PAY FOR THAT.
SO I THINK THAT THAT WOULD JUST
BE I THINK AN IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION I WOULD MAKE FOR. A
DEPARTMENT FROM OUR FROM OUR
POINT OF VIEW HOW IT MIGHT BE
JUST A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
I'M I DID WANT ASK THE
DEPARTMENT WHETHER YOU AGREED
WITH THE L. A. AS ASSESSMENT
THAT. ON TOP OF- THE SECOND
FACILITY CLOSING THAT WITH THE
L. A. O. PROJECTED THAT WE
COULD BE CLOSING UP TO FIVE OF
TOTAL FACILITIES AND- WE
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT PROJECTION.
HE WELL FIRST LET ME ADDRESS
YOUR FIRST QUESTION AS IT
RELATES TO- SO WE HAVE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF FACILITIES
SO FOR EXAMPLE WE DO CONTRACT
WITH CALIFORNIA CITY AND OUR
CURRENT PROPOSALS JUST TO KEEP
CALIFORNIA CITY HAS A CONTRACT
CONTRACTED FACILITY WE TOTALLY
STAFF BUT WITH OUR STAFF BUT
YOU ARE CORRECT THAT THE
PHYSICAL PLANT IS MAINTAINED BY
THE CONTRACTOR THE FACILITIES
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CLOSING OR COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES THAT
ARE- VERY SMALL FOOTPRINTS
LOWER LEVEL OFFENDERS- SO WE'RE
LIMITED ON WHAT WE ARE WHO WE
CAN HOUSE THERE. AND THEY
GENERALLY DO NOT HAVE- A HIGHER
LEVEL SECURE PERIMETER SO IT
DOES LIMIT US ON WHO CAN HOUSE
THERE THE CURRENT ONE THAT IS
SCHEDULED TO CLOSE IN MAY AS
OUR LAST- FEMALE OFFENDER
PROGRAM WHICH IS A MCFARLANE
CALIFORNIA- AND SO THAT'S THE
LAST. ONE THAT IS SCHEDULED TO
CLOSE. AND NOW I'VE LOST MY BY
JENNIFER AS TO GET RESERVE
QUESTION WAS JUST REGARDING
WERE YOU AGREE WITH L. A.
ELSESSER THAT POTENTIALLY UP TO
FIVE FACILITIES COULD BE CLOSED
IN THE FUTURE. IN THE NEAR
FUTURE. WELL OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE
TO MAKE DECISIONS AND COBIZ
TAUGHT US A LOT AS IT RELATES
TO PHYSICAL PLANT OF OUR
FACILITIES. AND HOW WE HOUSE-
OFFENDERS- I WILL SAY NOBODY.
KNEW AS FAR AS THAT OPEN CELL.
CELL PHONES AS WELL AS YOUR
SETTINGS. ON HOW RAMPANT IT
WOULD GROW WITHIN THOSE
ENVIRONMENTS SELECTED ITEMS
SECRETARY GIVE AN ANSWER FOR MY
QUESTION PLEASE. HONESTLY I
THINK IT'S PREMATURE TO MAKE AN
ESTIMATE OF FIVE INSTRUCTORS I
DID WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
WHAT WHAT ARE THE TRAILER BILLS
THAT WE ARMY- THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED LAST YEAR AND INTO LAW
WHICH WAS. AROUND ASKING
DEPARTMENT TO DO- CAPITAL
PLANNING AND THE REASON I ASK
FIVE FACILITIES IT IS
IMPORTANT. BECAUSE WITH DVR ONE
OF THE CONCERNS THE LEGISLATURE
HAD IS COMING TRUE HELLO WE'RE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF CLOSING A
PRISON WERE CLOSING DVI AT A
TIME AFTER. WE HEARD THE
RECEIVERS INSTRUCTION PUT IN A
BRAND NEW- HICK HICK THERE BY
FORGOT THAT WHAT STANDS FOR BUT
HEALTH CARE FACILITY WHICH I
THINK APPROXIMATE COST US
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS TO SO
BASICALLY WE PUT IN A BRAND NEW
CARE FACILITY I GOT I GOT
COLLEGE SHAKING THEIR HEAD I'M
GLAD TO SEE THAT. ON THERE AND-
AND THAT ON. THIS IS THIS IS A
YOU KNOW VERY. SIGNIFICANTLY SO
WE WERE TOLD BY YOUR STAFF THAT
THEY WOULD NOT BE- FOLLOWING
THE LAW AND WHAT WAS REQUIRED
IN THE TRIPLE BY IGNORING US
ARE. THOSE ARE NATURAL OKAY.
OUR SYSTEM RIGHT BUT- BUT THAT
THEY WERE JUST GONNA BE
IGNORING- THAT PART OF THE
BUDGET AGREEMENT SO COULD YOU
CLARIFY AND MAYBE ELIMINATE TO
US WHY THE STAFF IS DECIDING
TO- NOT GIVE US THIS VERY
CRITICAL INFORMATION SO THAT WE
DON'T CONTINUE TO. THROW AWAY
THE PUBLIC'S MONEY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I THINK- I KNOW YOU HAVE
THE NEXT HEARING WE HAVE IS-
DEDICATED TO CAPITAL OUTLAY AND
I THINK ONE OF THE TOPICS IT'S
GOING TO COME OUT THIS- PESAR
EL OR SUPPLEMENTARY. LANGUAGE
THAT I THINK YOU'RE- YOU'RE
MENTIONING- REGARDING
EXPERIMENTATION OF PROJECTS- WE
WILL JUST SAY THAT. FROM
COOKING UP FROM THE SECRETARY
SHE'S CHOOSING CHARGE. WELL I
WILL SAY THAT- WE'RE I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO HAVE OUR
FACILITIES MANAGEMENT ADDRESSED
THAT VERY SPECIFIC CONCERN YOU
KNOW DECISIONS ARE MADE I DON'T
THINK ANY OF US IN NEW WHEN
SOME OF THESE DECISIONS WERE
MADE THAT OUR POPULATION WOULD
REDUCE AS DRASTICALLY AS IT DID
NOBODY FOR SAME COVERAGE AND
THAT DRASTIC REDUCTIONS THAT
WE'VE SEEN WE DO HAVE TO
MAINTAIN OUR FACILITIES FOR
THOSE WHO LIVE THERE- AS LONG
AS THEY LIVE THERE I CANNOT
HAVE LEAKY ROOFS OVER OFFENDERS
HOUSING UNITS. AND WE HAVE ON
ALL WE DON'T WE DON'T DISAGREE
WITH YOU WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT
SAYING THAT WE SHOULDN'T DO
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WE ARE
JUST ASKING FOR A PLAN OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE SO THAT WE
DON'T CONTINUE TO WASTE THE
PUBLIC'S MONEY. PUTTING IN
MONEY FOR TO. DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FOR FACILITIES
WHICH WE ARE GOING TO CLOSE.
WHAT AND WHAT I WOULD SAY WE DO
HAVE A HEARING ON THIS AS AN
EXPERIENCE I WOULD I WOULD URGE
THE SECRETARY TO HEAR THE
MEMBERS FRUSTRATIONS AND
QUESTIONS THE ONE ASK YOU THEN
COME PREPARED- TO. TO GIVE US
SOME BETTER ANSWERS AT THE NEXT
HEARING ON THIS TOPIC THAT'S-
THAT'S THE FIVE. IT ADOPTABLE
REQUESTING A MEETING WITH YOUR
FACILITIES- THE PROPER
FACILITIES PERSON HAVE A
DISCUSSION. ON THAT DIRECTLY.
SO I WILL MAKE THANKS TO
COMMENTS AND THEN I DO HAVE TO
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PANEL JUST
TRYING TO MINDFUL OF TIME- THE
CLOSING OF THAT PERSON WITH
PLAN BEFORE COVE IT. ON AND SO
WE CAN'T PUT- WE CAN'T PUT THE
BLAME ON COVER FOR WHERE WE
SPENT THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS ON
A HEALTH CLINIC IN ORDER TO
CLOSE THE PRISON DOWN ON AS I
THINK WE NEED A BETTER ANSWER
COME NEXT HEARING- IN ADDITION
TO THAT- EVEN WITH THE DROP IN
POPULATION. BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE FOR EXPECTING A PLANE
COMPENSATION TO ALL BY TWO
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS TO
AND SO WE DO HAVE SOME PLANNING
THAT WE NEED TO DO TO MAKE SURE
YOU SEEN OUR TAX DOLLARS AS
WISELY AS POSSIBLE MOVING
FORWARD AND SO- I APPRECIATE
THE SECRETARY'S TIME. I
UNDERSTAND YOU'VE BEEN HERE A.
LITTLE BIT LONGER THAN I'VE
BEEN HERE BUT NOT MUCH LONGER-
BUT THE- THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR
YEARS AND- A LOT OF HIS
FRUSTRATIONS ARE ONGOING-
BEFORE BECAUSE OF IT AND WE
HOPE THAT. WITH YOUR- TENURE WE
COULD TURN THINGS AROUND AND
HAVE. A BETTER RELATIONSHIP-
AND A BETTER PROCESS THE
PLANNING. FOR CLOSER CENTER
BUDGET DOLLARS. SOME THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND MOVE US TOWARDS
SECOND PANEL. FOR A SECOND
PANEL WE HAVE THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL WHO WILL
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF PART THE
OTHER COVERT NINETEEN. REVIEW
OF THE STATE PRESENTS. THE
RECEIVER'S OFFICE WILL PROVIDE
A STATUS UPDATE ON CDC OURS
ONGOING MITIGATION EFFORTS. WE
HAVE TO THE PANELISTS WITH THIS
DAY WE HAVE ROY WESLEY OUR
INSPECTOR GENERAL. CLARK KELSO
ARE FEDERAL RECEIVER AND CDCR
STAFF WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS FROM THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND SO I WILL- WE WILL HAVE TO
BEGIN EMPANELING OFF THE PANEL
PANELIST TO PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF BEFORE YOU SPEAK. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME HERE TODAY. I'M ROY
WESLEY. THE CALIFORNIA ALL OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL. I WILL
ADDRESS THE THREE REPORTS MY
AGENCY COMPLETED AT THE REQUEST
OF THE HONORABLE ANTHONY RENDON
SPEAKER THE ASSEMBLY. IN ANSWER
TO HIS REQUEST WE BROKE THE
PROJECT INTO THREE BROAD PIECES.
THE FIRST WAS A REVIEW ON HOW
THE DEPARTMENT SCREEN STAFF AND
VISITORS WHO ENTERED THE
PERSON'S. WE PUBLISHED A REPORT
ON THE SCREENING PROCESS ON
AUGUST EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY. AND WE FOUND THAT THE
SCREENINGS WERE NOT CONSISTENT
OR STANDARDIZED ACROSS THE
SYSTEM. WE UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
HAS SINCE BEEN REMEDIED. THE
SECOND PART WAS THE USE OF
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
WITHIN THE PRISONS AND INCLUDED
COMPLIANCE WITH MASS WEARING
PROTOCOLS. THAT PUT THAT REPORT
WAS PUBLISHED ON OCTOBER TWENTY
SIX TWO THOUSAND TWENTY. AND WE
FOUND THAT ALTHOUGH THE
DEPARTMENT MANDATED TO WEAR A
FACEMASK. ENFORCEMENT OF ITS
MANDATE WAS LACKS. OUR FINAL
REPORT ISSUED ON FEBRUARY FIRST
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
ADDRESSED THE TREATMENT OF
INCARCERATED PEOPLE. WHO WERE
SUSPECTED TO HAVE CONTRACTED
CODE NINETEEN OR WORK SUPPOSED
TO COVER NINETEEN. WITH A FOCUS
ON THE MOVE A MEDICALLY
VULNERABLE INCARCERATED PERSONS.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION
FOR MEN TO SAN QUENTIN STATE
PRISON. AND CALIFORNIA STATE
PRISON CORCORAN. THE LATEST
REPORT ALSO INCLUDES AN
ANIMATED TIMELINE DETAILING THE
OUTBREAK OF THE VIRUS AT SAN
QUENTIN STATE PRISON. AND
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
CORCORAN. EACH OF OUR REPORTS
CAN BE FOUND ON OUR WEBSITE.
TODAY I'LL PROVIDE A SHORT
SUMMARY OF OUR LATEST REPORT.
THE LATEST REPORT DETAILS THE
ISSUES SURROUNDING THE MAY
TWENTY EIGHTH THROUGH MAY
THIRTIETH MOVES OF MEDICALLY
AFFORDABLE INCARCERATED PERSONS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION
FOR MEN. TO THE SAN QUENTIN
STATE PRISON AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRISON CORCORAN. LET ME
SAY AT THE OUTSET THAT THE
DECISION TO MOVE THESE MEN. WAS
WELL INTENTIONED AND REFLECTED
A CONCERN ABOUT THE HEALTH OF
THESE MEDICALLY FRAGILE
PATIENTS. I BELIEVE IT WAS
ABSOLUTELY. TO TRY TO PROTECT
THESE INDIVIDUALS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE EXECUTION OF
THESE MOVES WAS DEEPLY FLAWED.
REQUIREMENTS APPROVED BY THE
RECEIVER JUST ONE WEEK PRIOR TO
THE MOVES WERE NOT FOLLOWED BY
DEPARTMENT STAFF. WHAT ALARMS
RAISED BY MEDICAL STAFF THAT NO
TESTING HAD RECENTLY BEEN DONE.
THOSE CONCERNS OF MEDICAL STAFF
WERE IGNORED BY THEIR MANAGERS.
IN ADDITION LINE STAFFER UNDER
A MISTAKEN IMPRESSION FOSTERED
BY THOSE ABOVE THEM. THAT THE
MOVEMENT OF THE VULNERABLE
PATIENTS HAD TO HAPPEN BY A
HARD DATE. CURSORY PERSONS WERE
PUT ON BUSES. IN MOST CASES
WITHOUT APPROPRIATE TESTING.
WITHOUT APPROPRIATE SYMPTOMS
SCREENING AND WITHOUT
APPROPRIATE PHYSICAL DISTANCE.
FOR THOSE ARRIVING AT SAN
QUENTIN STATE PRISON. ONCE THEY
REACH THEIR DESTINATION THEY
WERE NOT PLACED AN APPROPRIATE
ISOLATION OR QUARANTINE. EVEN
THOSE WHO WERE SYMPTOMATIC WHEN
THEY REACH TANK WERE NOT
IMMEDIATELY SEGREGATED.
MULTIPLE CUSTODY STAFF
REGULARLY WORK IN NUMEROUS
AREAS OF THE PRISON. AND
INITIALLY NO MODIFICATIONS WERE
MADE TO CUSTODY STAFF
ASSIGNMENTS. TO ENSURE THAT
STAFF DID NOT CARRY INFECTION
FROM ONE PART OF THE PRESENT TO
OTHER PARTS OF THE PROJECT. IT
IS LIKELY THAT CUTS THE STAFF
ON WITTINGLY CARRIED THE VIRUS
TO MULTIPLE PLACES WITHIN THE
PRISON. FINALLY IT DOES NOT
APPEAR THAT ENOUGH THOUGHT WAS
GIVEN TO WHETHER THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF SAN QUENTIN.
WITH ITS OPEN SELF FRONT
ARCHITECTURE MAYBE IT'S PRISON
ON APPROPRIATE CANDIDATES TO
RECEIVE THESE MEGA. THE FAILURE
TO PROPERLY TEST AND SCREEN THE
PEOPLE BEING TRANSFERRED
INAPPROPRIATE HOUSING. AND LACK
OF INTERNAL SAFEGUARDS TO
ENSURE STAFF WITHOUT VECTORS TO
THE SPREAD OF THE DISEASE. LED
TO AN OUTBREAK OF ENORMOUS
PROPORTIONS. AT SAN QUENTIN.
I'D LIKE TO SHOW YOU AN
ANIMATION OF THE TIME I MIND
THAT WE DEVELOPED. OF THE
OUTBREAK AT SAN QUENTIN.
THANK
YOU AND I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU I'M GONNA GO THROUGH
THE PANEL PRESENTATIONS FOR
THIS IS SHERRY BEFORE WE TAKE
QUESTIONS SO WE COULD HAVE OUR
SECOND SPEAKER. MADAM CHAIR
GARCIA- AND- MY NAME'S CLARK
ALSO AND I SORT OF THE FEDERAL
RECEIVER RESPONSIBLE FOR
MEDICAL CARE WITHIN CDCR. TODAY
I WANT TO GIVE YOU A CALL WITH
THE UPDATE. CCAR'S EXPERIENCES
SIMILAR TO THE EXPERIENCE
NATIONWIDE OF OTHER
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES AND
CONGREGATE LIVING ENVIRONMENTS
SUCH. AS SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. THE ARE NOT SAFE
ENVIRONMENTS IN WHICH TO BE HOW
OR DO WORK DURING A HAND. WE
FOLLOW THE DEVELOPING SCIENCE
ON CLIMATE DALY AND WITH THE
HELP OF OUR INTERNAL AND
EXTERNAL PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH THE
CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION. WE ARE IMPROVING
OUR POLICIES PROCEDURES AND
PRACTICES ON A CONSTANT BASIS.
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE THE
PRESIDENT'S AS SAFE AS POSSIBLE.
WE ARE. EXPERIENCED EXACTLY THE
SAME WAVES OF COLD WEATHER AS
THE REST OF CALIFORNIA. THE
MOST SERIOUSLY BEGAN IN EARLY
NOVEMBER AND C. C. R. P. ON
DECEMBER TWENTIETH AND IS NOW
FINALLY SUBSIDE. AS OF FEBRUARY
SOMEONE THEY'RE BUILT FORTY
EIGHT THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY CONFIRM THE PROGRAM
THE INMATE'S CASE. M.
450-005-0020 SIX OF THOSE HAVE
RULES ALL. THOSE WITH ONE
THIRTY SEVEN REMAINING ACTIVE
AS WELL YESTERDAY. THERE HAVE
BEEN TWO HUNDRED THE PATIENT
DEATHS. SHE ALSO SUFFERED FROM.
AS OF FEBRUARY FIFTH THURMOND
FIFTEEN FILE FOUR AND FIFTY
THREE CONFIRMS OPEN CASES WITH
WHAT. FOURTEEN THOUSAND HUNDRED
AND EIGHTEEN MOTORISTS ALL AN
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
STILL. THERE ARE MANY TWENTY
FIVE STAFF THIS. YES MA'AM. I
AM VERY GOOD PIECES MOVEMENTS
PERHAPS THE BEST MILLIONS IN A
YEAR STRAWSON DIFFICULT. FIRST
STARTED IT GOES OVER THE COURSE
OF THE LAST YEAR THE RISK TO
CARPOOL WITH PATIENTS OF THE
HOSPITALIZATION AND DEATH.
SEVENTEEN CREASED ABOUT 26%
EVERY NINETY DAYS. THIS MEANS
THAT SOMEONE TESTS POSITIVE FOR
GOVERNMENT TODAY M. C. C. R. IS
ABOUT 50% LESS LIKELY TO BE
HOSPITALIZED OR DIED. ANY OF
THAT SAME PERSON WORKING WITH
DEFICIT POSITIVE AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE BAND. DON'T
WORRY HAVE TOTALLY GOTTEN
BETTER AND MONITORING CARING
FOR AND TREATING ARTICLE WITH
PATIENTS. SECONDLY EVEN BETTER
NEWS IS THAT WE HAVE STARTED
VACCINATING ANIMALS VULNERABLE
PATIENTS ONES MOST LIKELY TO BE
HOSPITALIZED FOR TONIGHT. I AM
HAPPY TO REPORT THAT THE FIRST
ALLEGATION OF AXIOMS WAS
RECEIVED ON DECEMBER TWENTY
FIRST AT THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
CARE FACILITY IN STOCK.
INITIALLY EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
DOSES OF FIGHTER AND BUT THERE
ARE NONE OR IN MEDIA
DISTRIBUTION. TO HIGHEST RISK
PATIENTS WHAT ARE THE
EQUIVALENT OF NURSING HOMES THE
FACILITIES. I AM BRANCH
ADMINISTRATION FOR ELIGIBLE
STAFF YEAH THE RATING FROM THE
VISUAL STARTED ON DECEMBER
TWENTY SECOND. LESS THAN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS AFTER WE RECEIVED
THE FIRST CHECK. WE ARE
PRIORITIZING BACKING
DISTRIBUTION IN A MANNER
CONSISTENT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDELINES. GLORIA STEINEM
240-007-0070 NINE INMATES AND
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY A STAFF AND I
RECEIVED THE FIRST DOSE OF THE
VACCINE. AND WE ARE KEEPING
PACE WITH THE SECOND DOSE IS
EVER BAR. THANKS THE ASIANS ARE
THE ONLY REAL SOLUTION TO MANY
OF THE NEARLY HAVE A SOLVABLE
PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
DEALING WITH AND MANAGING OUR-
IMAGINATION WILL HELP STAFF.
LOCAL OP AND THE COMMUNITIES
THE POOREST WE QUICKLY-
SUPPLIED. YOU BRING AVAILABLE I
WERE. ALL LITTLE SIX AGO I
GONNA TESTIFYING BEFORE THIS
PUBLIC SAFETY. I AM ALWAYS THE
MOVE PATIENTS FROM C. I AM TO
SEVEN POINT AN IMPORTANT. TO
AND BEFORE WE TAKEN THE TIME
ADEQUATELY PREPARE AND TRY ALL
THE NEW MOVEMENT PROTOCOLS THAT
HAD JUST BEEN INVOLVED. IN THE
WEEK PRIOR TO THE MOON. THE
MATERIALS REPORT AWAY. I THINK
IT'S CONFIRM WHAT I SAW SIX
MONTHS. AND I WON'T. THE ALLIED
WORK. AND IT'S DETAIL. WE WERE
TRYING TO MOVE QUICKLY WITH THE
TWO BIG. YES ARE ONLY TO PAY OF
IMPORT COMMENTS. MORE FULLY
DISCUSS BUT I THINK THE O. R.
G. REPORT. FIRST I THINK RECORD
ALL DOWN. THE REASON FOR THE
TRANSFER. IN THE BRONX LOSES OF
THE LAW BIRD. DECISIONS THAT
MADE DURING THE- GLOBAL SPRAY
WITHIN SPEED I AM. AND WE FACED
A SIR THAT IF WE NOT. ANOTHER
THOUSAND RATHER AND CHAU WOULD
ALLOW BE IN FACT. AND A NUMBER
THOSE NOT. REDUCING THAT RISK
WAS THE- URGENCY. AND NUMBER
TWO IT IS. THROUGH THE
ATTEMPTED MOVE. THERE WAS NO
ARTIFICIAL URGENCY THERE WAS NO
BUREAUCRATIC AND DEVIL SO WITH
THE MOVE. AND WE MAY LOCAL BUT
STILLTHE FEDERAL. THERE WAS
URGENCY ALL BECAUSE OF TRAILER.
AND SEE I AM. WE WERE MOVED
QUICKLY. IN REFERENCE- GREAT.
BECAUSE THE OF THE MOMENT WE
FOUGHT FOR THAT TYPE OF BACK.
THANK. IT MADE IT MADE. TWENTY
IN THE CONTEXT OF WHAT WAS
KNOWN ABOUT FM TIME. ALTHOUGH
WE IS NOT CLEAR THAT DON'T SEE
BE. AND HOW SUCH AS A AND-
BECAUSE THE VIRUS BY AEROSOL
SAFE SHARE ERRORS. PUBLIC
HEALTH AGENCIES BACK IN MAY.
BELIEVE CODES FOR BY. MARC
SAUSAGE. THAT ALONG WITH IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE ASSUME
DROPPED ONLY TRANSFER. THE
SPACE PARKING WHAT HAVE BEEN A
PART PLACE FOR POOR. AND TO
TEST THE PATIENCE OF FROM C.
HIGH. SPACEBALL DON'T AT THE
TIME WE THE SAMPLE WAS SAFER
PLACE THAN I AM FOR THE SENATE.
AS WE WERE. AND ULTIMATELY
CONFIRM AS FOR DISEASE TO AND-
IN OCT. OF LAST YEAR. GO FOR IT.
MINOR RENTALS ARE. ABSOLUTELY
THE SAN JOAQUIN TRADE. THE ONE
REPORT ON I THINK CORRECT THAT
ONE REASON DID NOT A SIMILAR UP
CORPORATION IS QUARANTINE SPACE
THERE WAS MORE. AT PREVENTING.
ULTIMATELY WE LEARNED FROM THE
SAMPLE NOW IT. THEN THERE'S THE
I THE REPORT INDICATES WE SAW
THE PROBLEM MADE A SINCE NUMBER
OF IMPROVE. ALL SEASON
PROCEDURE RELATED TO MANAGING
OPERATE AND MOVING. SO THEY
SAID QUITE UNTIDY FAILURE HAS
NOT HAPPENED AGAIN. IMPOSING
ONE REARRANGED THE WE HAVE
LOOKING FOR TO IMPROVE. ON FOR
WE KNOW WE CAN NEVER THE
MOVEMENT AND STUFF THE LIST
PARTNERS NO MATTER HOW HARD WE
TRY. AS ONE DATASET. IT FRONT
OF MYERS FOR DESIGNED IF I DEAL
ALL. IT WOULD BUILD A PER.
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR OUR
COMMITTEE MEETING THAT'S FINE
WILL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER. I
DON'T REMEMBER THE REST. THANK
YOU DO WE HAVE ANY COMMENT FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OR FIGHT A
FINANCE OR ALEJO. MORROW THE L.
A. O. NO FOR THE COMMENT. THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I
DON'T THINK HE WOULD DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NO FURTHER COMMENT
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU AND I
HAVE. A SERIES OF QUESTIONS
FROM THE ON GOING TO THAT THE
FIRST ONE AND THEN. I'M GOING
TO PASS THAT TO MR LACKEY TO
ASK THIS QUESTION OF XTC HAD
EARLIER. THANK YOU BOB MY
QUESTION- I KNOW MISTER KELSO
YOU SPOKE ABOUT THE FACT THAT
WE'VE HAD A SIMILAR SEARCH IN
THE PRESENCE OF THE PAD IN THE
PUBLIC BUT THE PRESIDENT THERE
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT SYSTEM
WE HAVE A CONTROL SPACE- WHERE
WE HAVE STAFF THAT ARE SUPPOSE
TO BE DOESN'T REGULARLY PEOPLE
ARE SUPPOSED TO VERY MATH WE
HAVE WITH WILL BE SCREENING
PEOPLE AND THEY ENTERED THE
PRINCESS. KEEPING PEOPLE
SEPARATED- AND SO FORTH I AND
SO IT'S NOT THE SAME AS THE
GENERAL PUBLIC OUT THERE TO
VERY DIFFERENT CONTROLLED SPACE
AND WHILE WE CAN'T COMPLETELY
STOP THE SPREAD OF COVERAGE WE
COULD DEFINITELY MITIGATE THE
CASES OR HOW QUICKLY IT
SPREADING INSIDE IN THE CAR
ABOUT A LITTLE BIT OVER TIME.
AND SO DO YOU NOW THAT YOU ARE
SAYING YOU. YOU'RE LEARNING
SOME LESSONS- AND WE CAN MAYBE
ADMIT THAT THE POLICIES WERE
NOT SUFFICIENT TO BEGIN WITH
HOW ARE WE ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE COMPLIANCE ACROSS ALL
THIRTY FIVE STATE TO THAT-
FOLKS ARE WEARING THEIR MATH WE
ARE SOCIALLY DISTANCING WE ARE
USING ALL THE BEST PRACTICES WE
ARE ADHERING TO WHAT THE CDC IS
RECOMMENDING OUT THERE NOWTEN
MONTHS DOWN THE ROAD WITH
LESSONS LEARNED. I'M SURE- I
THINK IT TO ASPECTS OF YOUR
QUESTION I THINK. ON THE FIRST
IS WHAT WE ACTUALLY WANT TO TRY
TO MAKE URE WE HAVE MASK
WEARING. ON AND JUST INSANE
RIDICULOUS BY STAFF WILL ALSO.
BY INMATES. OF THE ANSWER THAT
IS FOLLOWING ME ALL RIGHT
REPORTER. STEPPED UP
ENFORCEMENT. OF DISCIPLINE.
INCLUDING I HEARD RECENTLY
DISCIPLINE UP TO THE LEVEL OF
WORK- WAS NOT. WEARING A MASK.
FOR AND WE'RE LOOK THEM IMPROVE
LEVEL. OF THE COURT- I HAVE THE
OLD OF INSPECTOR GENERAL. IT
WAS JUST YOU KNOW I'M- AND WILL.
ON THOSE OF COMPLIANCE. SO I
THINK OF STUFF ARE BEING TAKEN
THE TO RECRUIT COMPLY. THIS
PART OF THE- EVEN WITH A FULL-
YOU'RE RIGHT IT'S SORT OF A
CONTROLLED AND- BUT IS A
CONTROLLING. WHERE YOU'VE GOT
NINE. TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
CLOSE. PROXIMITY TO EACH OTHER.
M. EVEN WITH COMPLIANCE THIS IS
A HIGH SETTING. FOR AN
INFECTION DISEASE QUICKLY AS
WHY THIS IS BEEN A AROUND THE
COUNTRY ON ALL JAIL. THIS IS A
CENTRAL. IF YOU HAPPEN PEOPLE
ON THE FLOOR IS. DEALING IN OUR.
ALONG WITH CONTRACT. OVER THE
LONG TO MAKE ITS WAY YOU. YEAH
BEFORE CHRISTMAS NINE ONE POINT.
FOR WHY WOULD YOU UP SEEING AND
WHOLE. OF MALCOLM CORRECTIONS.
IS THAT. WE INVITE. ACCESS AS A
MAN. ANY THAT'S HAPPENING IN
THE COMMUNITY IT'S GOING TO BE
GLORIFIED TIMES WORSE. IN THE
CAR STILL AND MEDICARE. AND M.
RUSSELL. WHAT THAT REALLY IS
THE FACT. IS THAT MUCH MORE- SO
IT KNOW THAT THINGS ARE GONNA
BE WORSE- IN THESE FACILITIES I
AM GONNA HAVE TO HAVE THE PUSH
BACK ON HOW WE PLANNED THEN
ACCORDINGLY AND HOW WE ENSURE
THAT WE ARE FOLLOWING
RECOMMENDATIONS AND REDEEMED
THE REPORT FROM THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL THERE WAS LACKS
IMPLEMENTATION- ALL OVER THE
pPLACE EVEN AS IT READ THE
REPORT ABOUT ENFORCEMENT. OF
STATUS OVER THERE'S NOTHING TO
BE AT LEAST AS OF NOVEMBER A
LOT OF ENFORCEMENT GOING ON A
LOT OF LITTLE WHETHER IT'S
VERBAL OR WRITTEN COUNSELING-
WITH STAFF ABOUT SIMPLE THINGS
LIKE MATH WEARING OUT THERE AND
IF WE ARE GOING TO BE RELYING
ON THE VACCINES HOW ARE YOU
DEALING WITH THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT DO NOT WANT TO BE
VACCINATED ARE WE MODIFYING
THEIR WORK ASSIGNMENTS WHO
LIMIT THEIR CONTACT. WITH
PRISONERS AND OTHER STUFF. WELL
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION-
GENERALLY- SO FAR ALONG ON OUR-
IN POPULATION- THE OFFICE TODAY.
BY YEAH MAYES THEM EXTRA. HIGH
FOR BANKS. ALMOST EVERY FOR.
AND START STAMINA- WE RISK.
NINETY ACCEPTANCE. RATES NOW WE
HAVE EXPANDED DROPPED BEAT UP
DOWN TO MORE HIGH 8285% PERHAPS
TO TALK TO LOWER. FONG WHAT DO
ABOUT SO THE BILL'S GOING WERE.
EITHER A WEEK'S MANY OF OUR OF
OUR INMATES SURVEYS THAT WE'VE
DONE- ELIMINATED THEY JUST
DON'T WANT. TO TAKE A FIRST.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS ELSE
TAKES. SO WE CONSTANTLY GO BACK
TO THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN IN
WERE. I YEAH WE ARE DISCOVERING
THAT AS HAS THERE INCREASE
TAKING A BACKSEAT. BARNSTEAD
BILL THAT. IS CONTINUING TO BE
A WORK AND- WE DO HAVE ON STAFF
JUST AS IN THE FREE WORLD WE
HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE SUSPICIOUS
OF VACCINES. WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO
STILL DON'T BELIEVE. HELLO THE
CODE IS THREE. WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHO ARE WAITING TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS. ALL RIGHT WE'RE DOING
THE SAME VITAMINS STAFFING
TRYING TO GO BACK THE STAFF ON
AS THEY SEE OTHER PEOPLE TAKING
THE VACCINE AND WHEN ONE WAS
LOOKING NOT HAVING BABIES SIDE
EFFECTS. OVERSEEING AN
INCREASING PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE
SAY YES SO I HAVE BEEN OUR
INITIAL APPROACHES WHILE WE'RE
PUSHING OUT THE VACCINE
PROGRAM. LET'S SEE IF WE CAN'T
GET AS. MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE.
I WANTED TO USE- UNDERTAKING-
ANALYSIS ABOUT WHAT WE DO WHEN
WE- THE OPEN AND- WE WON'T.
PRESENT SO WHAT DO WE DO THAT
TWENTY ARMENIANS ARE OF.
AMISTAD BUT UNTIL IT CAME
THROUGH THEM AND MAKE THE RIGHT.
I'M NOT HERE TODAY TO SAY WHAT
WE MIGHT END UP RECOMMEND IS
IT'S GOING TO BE A PROBLEM
PROBLEM AND THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
BEST A GREAT QUESTION. SO THANK
YOU FOR ALL THAT INFORMATION
BUT I ACTUALLY. DON'T THINK YOU
ANSWERED MY QUESTION- WHAT ARE
WE DOING EVERY MODIFYING
SCHEDULES VERY MODIFYING
HOUSING IN THE MOMENT FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT DO NOT WANT TO
BE VACCINATED BECAUSE THEN THE
MOMENT. WE NEED TO TAKE ACTION
AND PHIL I UNDERSTAND WE'RE
GONNA COME BACK TO THEM A
SECOND TIME IN A THIRD TIME.
BUT WHAT ARE WE DOING IN THE
MOMENT TO MODIFY. EXPOSURE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION
CORRECTLY I THINK THE ANSWER IS
WE'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING IN
TERMS OF MODIFYING. HOUSING
UNITS. IN THE LOWER ONE WE'RE
STILL. TRYING SIMPLY TO GET AS
MANY PEOPLE. HOUSE NOT THE TIME.
TO START FOR EXAMPLE SAY WELL
IF YOU DON'T YOU'RE GONNA MOVE.
THE PRESIDENT THE US- PLEASE
THOSE. FOR SO WE HAVE BE
CAREFUL ABOUT THAT WE ARE- TRY
TO MAKE SURE THOSE BE WHO ARE
NOT TAKE THE MAX. WE'RE
WATCHING ESPECIALLY CAREFULLY
ABOUT. ON IT ABOUT DISTANCE.
AND THEIR WHEN I DON'T TERM. AS
WE GET. OTHER REST OF THE
MAXIMUM BROKE. WELL LOOK NO ARE
GONNA BE RECOMMENDED ABOUT HOW.
BUT WE'RE NOT MAKING A QUICK
DECISION ABOUT MOVEMENT OF
PEOPLE. FROM PEOPLE ACTUALLY
WITH COLD IN THE PROP. AND WHAT
ABOUT THE PATH OF THE TO BE
BACK. YEAH EYES YEAH I DO WITH
ME ON THIS THING DR JONES BIT
WITH OUR TREATMENT OFFICE WOULD
YOU LIKE PROVIDE A- FOR. THANKS
FOR I'D GIVEN IF YOU NEED MORE.
YEAH AND I WOULD LIKE AN
EXPLANATION ALSO WITH STAFF WHO
IS A VACCINATED I THINK NOT
DOING ANYTHING IS HOW WE GOT
INTO THIS PROBLEM ON AND SO I
THINK WE NEED TO LEARN FROM
PAST MISTAKES AND BE A LITTLE
MORE PROACTIVE. TO PROTECT
EVERYONE WHETHER IT'S OUR
PRISONERS THEIR FAMILIES ARE
OUR WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
UP UNTIL I'M SORRY. FOR DR.
VISITS BENEFIT BECAUSE I JUST
POSTED THE HIM BEFORE HE WAS
PERHAPS. WHAT WOULD YOU
QUESTION SO HE CAN ADDRESS IT
PROPERLY. IF A STAFF MEMBER
REFUSES TO GET VACCINATED WELL
YOU MODIFY THEIR WORK
ASSIGNMENTS TO LIMIT CONTACT
WITH OTHERS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT
ALTHOUGH I'M NEVER HAPPY WITH
THE PACE OF ANY OF OUR
INITIATIVES ARE WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE NUMBERS THIS WEEKEND IN
JUST THE LAST FIVE MEETINGS.
WE'VE MANAGED IT ACTS MAY HAVE
OVERSTAFFED WE'RE NOT. WE'RE
NOT GETTING SOME OF THE- WHEN
YOU PUT THAT WITH THE FIFTEEN.
ALREADY HAVE. WE WILL PASS
THIRD OF OUR STAFF WRITER
THAT'S NEEDED. OR HAVE SOME
DEGREE OF IMMUNITY BECAUSE
HAVING HAD. THIS IS JUST FROM
THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR SO.
WE REMAIN VERY OPTIMISTIC. A
LARGE NUMBER LARGE PERCENTAGE
OF OUR STAY. GET ON BOARD ZACKS
NATION WE HAD A VERY DETAILED
ONLINE SURVEY AT THE BEGINNING
THIS EFFORT. ABOUT HALF OF THE
PEOPLE ONE OF THE VACCINE NOW
IN ANOTHER REPORTER SAID. TO
SEE MY BUDDY YOUR GOAL FIRST
ARE MORE. SO VERY OPTIMISTIC
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET A HIGH
TAXES OF ALONG BOTH OCCASIONS
AND IMPORTANT. OKAY SO I JUST
THAT READ THE IT THAT IS
SOMEONE RIGHT REVIEW TO GIVE
ACT AND- NOTHING IS BEING
MODIFIED. THIS TIME THEIR JOB
IS NOT BEING MODIFIED THEY ARE
BEING REQUIRED TO WEAR FACE
COVERINGS THAT ALL THE TIME AND
USE APPROPRIATE FISCAL
DISTANCING BUT THEY'RE NOT
BEING PENALIZED AT THIS TIME
OKAY JOB CHANGE OR NOT BEING
FIRST IN LINE FOR THE NEXT
THREE. OR WE COULD THINK ABOUT
IT THAT WE'RE- NOT PRIOR
EVERYONE'S HEALTH. OFTEN TRY TO
BE A SERVICE BY- I'M GONNA HAVE
WITH OUR VICE CHAIR- ****
QUESTION. I NOTICED WENT WHEN
YOU WERE A- SHOWING US THE
CONCENTRATION OF THE SPREAD OF
THE- OF THIS RECORD NINETEEN
PROBLEM. I THINK IT WAS
REFERRING ONLY TO THE INMATES I
WAS WONDERING IF THERE WAS THE
COMMENSURATE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE INMATES AND THOSE
WHO ARE SERVING THEM. THE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS WHO ALSO
CONTRACTED THAT MAY HAVE-
ONGOING CONDITIONS THAT WOULD
REQUIRE IN A WORKMAN'S COMP
COSTS. BECAUSE THOSE ARE ALL
VERY SIGNIFICANT BUDGET
CONCERNS THAT WE NEED TO PLAN
FOR. WELL I THINK YOU'RE ASKING
DID WE ANIMATE THE- SPREAD OF
THE DISEASE VICE FOR STAFF AND
THE ANSWER IS NO- THAT WAS- A
LITTLE BIT HARDER. PROCESS OF
THE WAY WE WERE ABLE TO ANIMATE
THE- SPREAD OF THE DISEASE OF
THE INCARCERATED POPULATION WAS
BY. PHYSICALLY MAPPING WHERE
THEIR BEDS WERE- THAT WE DIDN'T
HAVE THAT INFORMATION FOR UP
FOR STAFF WE JUST HAVE RAW
NUMBERS. OKAY SO. JUST TO
CLARIFY ON THIS PARTICULAR
ASPECT. THE CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS AND THE STAFF THEY
WERE DEALING WITH THE INMATES
HAD VERY LITTLE SPREAD. IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE TELLING ME. WELL
CERTAINLY NOT AS ARE NOT AS
DRAMATIC AS THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION- THE NUMBERS WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT- I'M
LOOKING TO SEE IF I HAVE HERE.
THE NUMBERS FOR THE- FOR THE
STAFF INFECTIONS I DON'T THINK
I HAVE THOSE- BUT IF WE COULD
GET ALONG TO BE HIGHLY
INTERESTED IN KNOWING WHAT WHAT
THEY ARE JUST FOR SAFETY
PURPOSES AND THOSE ARE
ACTUALLY- RESPONSIBLE FOR
CARING FOR THE INMATES I THINK
THAT WE HAVE A STRONG DUTY TO-
MAKE SURE THAT WE BUDGET.
APPROPRIATELY SOUGHT THEIR
COVERED FOR BECAUSE I CAN TELL
YOU A LOT OF THE HAVING BEEN A
PERSON THAT'S- ADULT WITH THE
VIRUS I HAVE ONGOING. HEALTH
ISSUES. THAT THE THEY'RE NOT
CHEAP. AND SO THESE ARE ALL
VERY SIGNIFICANT COSTS THAT WE
NEED TO BUDGET FOR AND THAT'S
ALL I'M TRYING TO I'M NOT
TRYING TO POINT FINGERS ANYBODY
I JUST WANT. INFORMATION SO WE
CAN PLAN ACCORDINGLY. WHAT WE
WILL CERTAINLY GET THAT
INFORMATION TO. MR DON'T FIRE.
AND THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ON.
BUT IT APPEARS THE CDC ARE HAS
ONCE AGAIN OPTED GATED THE
ISSUE. A STATE SENATOR BRADFORD
AND I BOTH WILL MAKE WITH THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION THE
PREVIOUS SECRETARY A SECRETARY
ALLISON THIS IS FOR YOU TO
KNOW. THAT WE ASKED ABOUT THE
SITUATION. WE WERE TOLD
SOMETHING COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
BENEFITS IN THIS REPORT. AND SO
IF WE'RE HARD ON YOU. YOU NEED
TO UNDERSTAND THE HISTORY OF
THIS COMMITTEE A MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE TRYING TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF THIS HAS BEEN
VERY VERY DIFFICULT. AND SO.
WHEN I FIRST GOT ON THIS
COMMITTEE. ARE TRYING TO GET
RID OF CLARK KELSO AS QUICK AS
POSSIBLE THE FEDERAL RECEIVER.
I NOW UNDERSTAND FULLY WHY. UP
FEDERAL RECEIVER HAS TO BE.
INVOLVED IN CDCR WE ALREADY HAD
THE REASON THEY'RE THERE
BECAUSE PATIENTS INMATES DIED
LEFT IN THE HALLWAY TO DIE. AND
NOW WE'RE HERE WITH COATED
WE'RE NOT ONLY INMATES ARE
DYING. CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
AND STAFF ARE DYING AND WE
DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY WERE AND
MOST IMPORTANT WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THE
FAMILY AND THE COMMUNITIES THAT
THEY WENT BACK TO THE PRISONERS
CAN'T GO BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY. SO OUR CONTRACT
TRACING. EVEN ON OUR OWN
EMPLOYEES WHICH SHOULD BE
PARAMOUNT TO EVERYBODY. IS
ABYSMAL AT BEST. AND SO. I
THINK AND IN ADDITION TO THE
FEDERAL RECEIVER THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL MR WESLEY HAS DONE A
SUPERB JOB AT TRACKING THIS AND
THESE ARE TWO INDIVIDUALS
OUTSIDE THE SYSTEM THAT CAN GO
INTO THE SYSTEM IN FACT WE
PROBABLY SHOULD GIVE THEM MORE
POWERS SO WE GET THIS
INFORMATION TO US QUICKLY
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT IS IT IS A
BIZARRE WHAT WE'RE GETTING
RIGHT NOW. AND SO WE NEED TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH NOT ONLY
MAKING SURE WE CLEAN THIS MESS
UP. THAT THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN THAT WE PUT IN PLACE THE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO MOVE
FORWARD. THANK. I'M GONNA
RECOGNIZED MR LEVINE WHO'S
JOINING US HERE TODAY WHO
REPRESENTS THE AREA THAT
INCLUDES THANK LEFT SAN QUENTIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
FOR- FOR WELCOMING ME TO THE
DAIS TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FEAR
REPORT I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THE ATTENTION THAT TELL YOU
BROUGHT TO THIS- MY GRATITUDE
ALSO EXTENDS THE SPEAKER- WHO
REQUESTED THIS- THIS AS WELL-
I'VE BEEN I'VE BEEN PAYING
ATTENTION TO THIS FOR. A VERY
LONG TIME AND- THEN I SEE THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S AND COVERED-
A VERY DISTURBING TRAIL- OF IT
KNOWLEDGE MEANT OF- OF THE
INADEQUATE PREPARATIONS THAT-
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
HAS SIDE HAD MADE. IN THE
SPRING AND THE- THE- INABILITY
FOR THE FEDERAL RECEIVERS
OFFICE TO MAKE ANY COURSE
CORRECTIONS- BUT INSTEAD
POWERHEAD WITH VERY BAD
DECISION MAKING AS EVIDENCED BY
THE EMAILS- THAT WE SEE- AND
ALSO THE KNOWLEDGE MEANT FROM
THE RECEIVER HIMSELF. THE- THE
EMAIL THAT I SEE ON ON THE FACT
SHEET DATED WEDNESDAY MAY
TWENTY SEVENTH- IT'S A PRETTY
SERIOUS THIS PRETTY SERIOUS
THEY THEY KNEW THAT THERE WAS A
PROBLEM. AND WHEN I STARTED.
REACHING OUT TO THE PARDON OF
CORRECTIONS- ALTERNATELY HAVING
A TELEPHONE CALL WITH WARDEN
BROOMFIELD A DOCTOR. CHECK AND-
UNDER SECRETARY REBAY I HAD
ASKED ABOUT PLANS AND
PREPARATIONS AT IN PARTICULAR
BECAUSE OF A CONCERN- A VALID
CONCERN BUT NOT LOOKING BACK
THE BIGGEST CONCERN I SHOULD'VE
HAD BUT BUT A CONCERN ABOUT.
THE IMPACT ON HOSPITALS AND
HOSPITALIZATION THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OUR PRISONS
ALL THIRTY FIVE FACILITIES- ARE
FREQUENTLY IN PLACES WHERE
THERE IS NOT. A GREAT DEAL OF
CAPACITY FOR HOSPITALS. AND I'D
I'D HADN'T CONSIDERED THE OTHER
MISSTEPS THAT WOULD LEAD TO
THIS PROBLEM- MY CONCERN WAS
THAT THE DUAL THREAT OF BOTH
THE COMMUNITY SPREAD AND SPREAD
IN A PRISON OPERATE OF CODED
BUT THE DATE. OF THIS EMAIL. OF
WEDNESDAY MAY TWENTY SEVENTH
IT'S A IT'S A REAL PROBLEM FOR
ME BECAUSE IT WAS JUST A DAY
BEFORE. THAT WE IN THE ASSEMBLY.
ORGANIZED AS A COMMITTEE OF THE
WHOLE. ON MAY TWENTY SIXTH TO
TALK ABOUT THE BUDGET. AND WITH
THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE
STANDING UP THERE LIKE A STATUE
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS RAISE
CONCERNS THEY HAD ABOUT THE
BUDGET. AND MY CONCERNS FOR
WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN WITH AN
APARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS FIELD
MOST OF THE FIVE MINUTES I HAD
THAT DAY. AND I I'D LOVE TO
HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WHAT DID YOU DO. WITH
ALL THE FEEDBACK YOU RECEIVED
ON THE BUDGET THAT DAY. I WAS
IN YOUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THANK U. S. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE I'M
GONNA HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
WITH SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION I WAS NOT A PART OF
THE CONVERSATION THAT YOU HAD.
AND I THINK. IF YOUR QUESTION
IS TO COVERT RESPONSE GENERALLY
I'M DEPARTMENT FINANCES BEEN
WORKING DILIGENTLY TO TRY TO.
ASSIST FUNDING FOR THAT IN
TERMS OF KIND OF OPERATIONAL
NEEDS I WOULD HAVE TO DEFER TO
THE DEPARTMENT. SO I THINK YOU
KNOW WHAT I'M INTERESTED IN
KNOWING IS. WAS THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCES. PARTICIPATION IN
THE COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE.
PERFORMATIVE OR DID THE
ADMINISTRATION PAY ATTENTION TO
THE ISSUES THAT LAWMAKERS WERE
RAISING THAT DAY. AND DO YOU
HAVE EVIDENCE. THAT THERE WAS
ANY RESPONSE TO THE ISSUES THAT
THAT WERE RAISED. BECAUSE
LOOKING AT THE EMAIL OF MAY
TWENTY SEVENTH. OR THE EMAIL OF
MAY TWENTY EIGHTH IT SEEMS LIKE
NO ONE NO ONE HEARD THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAD- THE AND
I'M NOT THE ONLY ONE THAT RAISE
CONCERNS. ABOUT CORRECTIONS BUT
IT SEEMS AS THOUGH IT IT NEVER
LEFT. THE ASSEMBLY THAT DAY.
WHEN THE DIRECTOR FINANCE
WALKED OUT. I'M THANK YOU FOR
THAT THE QUESTION WOULD JUST
SAYING AGAIN AT I AM CERTAIN
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION TOOK
ALL OF THE ASSEMBLY CONCERNS
UNDER CONSIDERATION I'M WE PUT
FORWARD A BUDGET THAT INCLUDED
I'M RESOURCE HERE I AM
INTERESTED TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO COPE DID WE HAVE A
BUDGET NOW AND ARE LOOKING AT
WAYS THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
FUND COVERT RESPONSE. I'M IN
TERMS OF ANY SPECIFICS ABOUT
CONVERSATION I WOULD HAVE TO IS
FOLLOW UP WITH OUR LEADERSHIP
AND GET BACK TO YOU BUT I THINK
THIS ADMINISTRATION AS A WHOLE
PARTICULARLY FOR CDC ARE
ANYTHING. AND SO MOTHER RIGHT
BIT APARTMENT CAN SPEAK TO A
LITTLE BIT I'M BETTER THAN
MYSELF AND SOME OF THOSE ARE
YOU KNOW OPERATIONAL DECISIONS.
INTERVENE HI. MAY QUICKLY BUT
TERMS OF THE RESOURCE
ALLOCATIONS AND WE HAVE
CERTAINLY BEEN PRIORITIZING
RESOURCES FOR COPING. NOT JUST
WITHIN CDCR BUT ACROSS THE
STATE. AND SO WE HAVE BEEN AND
LOOKING TO PARTNER WITH OUR- I
FEDERAL COUNTERPARTS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THEMATIC
RIGHT AWAY AND I THINK. AS MANY
RESOURCES AS POSSIBLE I
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE. FOR
I'M NOT SURE WHO CAN ANSWERED
MY NEXT QUESTION I DON'T I
DON'T. I WON'T. ASK YOU TO
ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS BECAUSE
I DON'T THINK THAT YOU'RE IN A
POSITION REALLY ADEQUATELY DEAL
WITH AN INSPECTOR GENERAL MIGHT
HAVE SOME INSIGHT. THE V-
GRAPHIC THE ANIMATION THAT YOU
PRESENTED- WITH SOMETHING THAT
THAT MY COMMUNITY EXPERIENCED
IN REAL TIME- CERTAINLY THE
PEOPLE IN SAN QUENTIN
EXPERIENCE IN REAL TIME. WHY
DID IT TAKE SO LONG TO TAKE THE
DISASTER SERIOUSLY AT SAN
QUENTIN I WAS CALLING. VERY
EARLY FOR- YEAH AN OPERATIONAL
COMMAND TO BE SET UP- FOR- AN
ALTERNATE CARE SITES TO BE SET
UP- FOR SPACING FOR THE
INCARCERATED PEOPLE TO LIMIT
SPREAD. NONE OF THIS TOOK PLACE
UNTIL JULY WHEN- YES GOT
INVOLVED WHY DID IT TAKE SO
LONG CAN ANYONE ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. HELLO THIS IS ROY
WESLEY- INSPECTOR GENERAL I
WOULD HAVE TO DEFER TO- MR
KELSO. OUR OUR REVIEW OF THE
PROCESS REALLY DIDN'T GO INTO
THE RESPONSE ONCE THE OUTBREAK
HAPPENED- WE LOOK AT THE OF THE
MOVEMENT OF THOSE INCARCERATED
PEOPLE AND THEM THE CONSEQUENCE
OF THAT MOVEMENT. AND DID NOT
LOOK AT THE UNDERLYING THE
AUTOCRAT THE ABSENT CLINTON
ONCE THAT HAPPENED WELL WE DID
NOTED OUR REPORT THAT SAN
QUENTIN APPEARED TO BE A LITTLE
SLOW AND- ISOLATING AND TESTING-
THE PEOPLE WHO ARRIVED AND THAT
WAS PROBABLY ONE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SAN QUENTIN AND
CORCORAN. BUT ONCE THE OPERATE-
I'D HAVE TO DEFER TO MISTER
COUNCIL ON ON WHAT I'M FINE HOW
THEY HANDLED THAT. MISTER YES
WE WERE GOING TO BE HERE- THANK
YOU MA'AM LET ME GO QUESTIONS I
DON'T THINK YOU'RE AWARE.
REALLY EARLY JUNE WHEN WE
REALIZE WE HAVE THE BEGINNINGS
OF AN OUTBREAK AT SAN QUENTIN
WELL I HAD ASKED- OUR EXPERT
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO AND
BERKLEY- TWO. SEVEN ONE TWO A
LOOK AT WHAT WAS HAPPENING
THERE AND MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
AS YOU KNOW. OF AB. OR BACK TO
ME AND GEN- INDICATING WHAT
THEY BELIEVE WAS GOING TO BE
USED. WHITE PLEASE. OF FOR. IN
A SERIES OF STEPS AND INCLUDING
SOME OF THE ONES YOU'VE
MENTIONED THAT NEEDED TO BE
TAKEN. I THINK THE REASON THAT
SO LONG AS BEST- CALLED AND I
DIDN'T COME HERE. TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION. I THE LEADERSHIP OF
SAN QUENTIN BOTH. AND SIMPLY
NOT OVER WHILE. I THINK YOU CAN
SEE THAT IN THE WHOLE WIDE
RECEIVER. THAT- WE JUST. WE ARE
SLOWING US TO REACT. YEAH
ULTIMATELY- THAT WAS RECOGNIZE
IN THE- I THINK OF THE RIGHT
THING BY BRINGING HIM THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICE
INSTEAD THE YOUNG COMMAND
CENTER. THANK GROUP QUICKLY
WENT WORKING STRUCTURE. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE LEARNED FROM.
WELL AS WE NEED TO HAVE A AND-
GAMES COME. UNIT CENTRAL.
AFRICAN I WOULD- NOT LONG
AFTER- BUT NOT SO THAT EVERY
INSTITUTION WHAT ORGANIZATIONAL
STRUCTURE PREPARED TO DEAL
WITH- OUTWARDS IT ULTIMATELY
SERVED AS WHITE WELL IN THE
NOVEMBER DECEMBER OUTBREAKS
WHICH BASICALLY WE HAVE
OUTBREAKS THROUGHOUT MOST OF
THE SYSTEM. WE ACTUALLY HAVE
THE SPORT OF YOU MIGHT. I WAS
GREATEST SYSTEM TOOLS. OKAY
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CALL SO IT SO YOU HAD MENTIONED
EARLIER IN YOUR PRESENTATION.
THE GOOD NEWS- AND YOU SAID
THAT THAT THE VERY SAME PERSON
TODAY WOULD BE LESS LIKELY TO
DIE THAN IN JULY. AND I'D LIKE
TO UNDERSTAND HOW YOU. HOW YOU
MODEL- THE INCARCERATED PEOPLE
ON THE PATIENTS AND THEIR RISK.
AND THEIR LIKELINESS TO DIE
FROM COVE ED. PURSES THE
REALITY THAT PERHAPS THE MOST
FRAGILE MEDICALLY VULNERABLE
INCARCERATED PEOPLE HAVE
ALREADY BEEN BEEN KILLED BY
CODE. I UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION
I'M BEING TURNED TO DR SHORTLY
AFTER I GET A- A WHAT I THINK
IS THE PROPER ANSWER. OUR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT UNIT WHICH
IS THE SUBJECT OF THE ISSUE.
THREE COMING UP ON. TABLE. TO-
OKAY- THE RISK FOR BASED ON
EVERY- IN MAINE'S AGE
COMORBIDITIES AND SO ON SO WE
ARE NOT HAVING CONGRESS FOR
SUPPORT EACH. INMATE DRAMA
SYSTEM. EARLY IT'S WELL WE HAVE
CREW GETS HOSPITAL ON. IN THE
WIDELY LOOK OF YEAH IF YOU
BECOME ACROSS. AND WE AS A
MATTER ALL OVER THOSE NINETY
DAYS SO THAT CRIED. NOTHING
HEREIN BASED. BOB WAS SO THAT
YOU CAN ACTUALLY MODEL. HERE IS
HOW MANY PEOPLE WOULD
HOSPITALIZE AND LIKELY WOULD
HAVE DIED. IF NOTHING CHANGED.
I'VE BEEN ON A PLANE THAT
DIRECTLY DR BILL- RIGHT ANY
MISTAKES AREN'T MADE ON THAT
ANSWER. I THINK THE ONLY THING
I WOULD ADD IS THAT YOU CAN
ALSO SAY THAT EVERY PATIENT IS
ASSIGNED THIS CALL RIGOROUS
SCORE YEAH EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
PATIENTS ALLOCATED CORPORATE
RESOURCES OR INCREASED RISK.
FOR HOSPITALIZATION AND DEATH.
THANK 9% OF OUR- HOUSE PATIENTS
SO THEY WERE A NUMBER OF STEPS
THAT WERE PUT IN PLACE.
IMPORTANT TO PROTECT PATIENTS
GOING FORWARD YEAH I HAD TO DO
WITH WHERE PATIENTS WITH
ELEVATED RISK SCORES COULD BE
PROBLEMS. HE MOVED FROM ONE
PLACE TO ANOTHER WHAT TYPE OF
MONITORING WOULD TAKE PLACE OF
PATIENTS DURING OUR BREAK SO WE
CAN RAPIDLY IDENTIFY THOSE THAT
NEEDED A HIGHER LEVEL OF CARE.
THE TYPE OF TREATMENT WAS
PROVIDED TO PATIENTS. WITH
DISABILITIES PRIOR TO THEM
HAVING TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL'S.
ON TOP OF THAT THERE DO YOU SEE.
IMPROVE IN COMMUNITY. IN TERMS
OF HOW PATIENTS ARE TREATED
WITH WRESTLING IMPLEMENTED
OTHER TREATMENTS SUCH AS THE
MONOCHROME ANTIBODY THERAPY IN
AN ATTEMPT TO DECREASE PEOPLE'S
SEVERITY OF ILLNESS. SO EVERY
ONE OF THEM TWO HUNDRED
PATIENTS DESPERATELY PATTERSON
AND TRAGIC BUT IT'S CERTAINLY A
PERSON ALL PERCENTAGE OF OUR
OVERALL RISK POPULATION. IN OUR
ALREADY SEEN WITH MORE
EXTENSIVE VACCINATION. THE RISK
OF PEOPLE BECOMING SEVERELY ILL
AFTER GETTING FIRST DOSE. SEEMS
TO BE INCREASING. THIS OF SOME
OF OUR OUR- I THANK DR BECK.
MMHM MR CALL SO HAD MENTIONED-
THAT- THAT WHAT WE HAD KNOWN
AND MISTER BECAUSE WHEN I TALK
ABOUT THIS AT THE LAST HEARING
THAT AT THAT POINT IN TIME HE
WAS AWARE THAT DROPLETS WERE A
THREAT. HE WAS NOT. CONVINCE
THE ASSOCIATION HAD BEEN
SCIENTIFICALLY ACCEPTED AS THE
THREAT- I THINK THAT MOST
PEOPLE USING COMMONSENSE KNEW
BETTER. BUT GIVEN WHAT YOU ARE
ACCEPTING HOW DID YOU MODEL SAN
QUENTIN IS APPROPRIATE IN A
TROPICAL ENVIRONMENT WHERE
THERE ARE NO CLOSED DOORS AND
ALL THAT BUT DROPLETS LIKE THAT
THAT. HOW DID YOU FIGURE THE
DISTANCE THE YOU KNOW SELL
SPACE HOW DID YOU PLAN THAT ONE
OF THE THIRTY FIVE FACILITIES.
FOR THE TRANS. REMEMBER THE
QUESTION. LET'S BE CLEAR ALSO I
DO NOT MAKE THESE DECISION BY
MYSELF ALL. WILL NOT BE INVITED
TO A PUBLIC ALL THE MEDICAL
LEADERSHIP. YOU FOR
RECOMMENDING RECOMMENDATIONS
MADE TO ME. ALTHOUGH I ON THE
ONE ACCOUNTABLE FOR MAKING THAT
DECISION BUT THE THAT'S WHY IT
STOPPED THE PROBABILITY FOR.
SIX MONTHS AGO. BUT IT'S NOT
JUST ME I'M RELYING UPON
EXPERTS WHO ARE FOLLOWING THE
FINAL PRETTY CLOSELY. IN
PARTICULAR AFTER SAM POINTON- I
THINK THE ANSWER IS THAT THE C.
I. M. ALL THE WERE ALREADY
VULNERABLE. YOU FOR MEMBERS WHO
HAVE MEDICAL NEEDS SERVICE.
YEAH IT WAS OF THE VIEW FIRST
THE TIME AT HIM YEAH- SO.
SUFFICIENT QUALITY OF MEDICAL
CARE AND ACCESS TO HOSPITAL
CARE SO THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
ADEQUATE HEALTHCARE ONLY APART
FROM PROBABLY. THESE WERE
PEOPLE WHO STILL HAVE MEDICAL
NEEDS. IN TERMS OF ALL ONE MY
STAFF ABOUT IT LONG LEVEL DROP
SPREAD GONNA BE A PROBLEM.
EIGHT THE SOLEMN BAYERN IS THE
ONLY MAKES SENSE. WE'RE STILL
OUTSIDE A HOUSE. THE DIFFERENCE.
DROPPED ONCE WHEN. IS YOU.
NUMBER PROBLEM SINCE FEET
ACROSS THE- THE GROUND. SO LONG
AS SAID IN A- YOU PROTECT.
THAT'S THE MODEL SAW SEVEN ONE.
HELLO I. T. EXAMINATION OF YOUR
SHOW YOU SO UP TO THE MAXIMUM.
BROWN IF I LOOK FOR. WELL WHEN
I WAS HAVE PEOPLE WITH TEARS
WHO BECAUSE OF THEIR ASIAN IT
WAS NOW. I AM A PART IS STILL
ON THE LINE OF SAN QUENTIN. AND
AS THE WORLD FROM THE U. CAL
INDICATED OF THE- WITH THOSE
UNITS. OF THE BILL SEEN SINCE-
FOR A ERROR- INSTEAD OF
PROMOTED AS MAY. WHERE ARE EVER
SOLVED SPREAD. MOST NO. THANK
YOU AND SO YOU KNOW ALTERNATE.
YOU DON'T YOU DIDN'T HAVE A
MODEL FORCE. WHEN THE CHOICE
WAS IN. AND IT WASN'T REALLY S.
OF WHAT WOULD BE A PRO. AND YOU
YOU TO MAKE IT. BASED RECOMMEND
AND I. CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT A
POSITION LIKE THAT WOULD BE.
WHO RECOMMENDED SAN QUENTIN IS
AN APPROPRIATE PLACE. MY WHY
IT'S ALMOST BLIND ON OTHERS. IN
THE WITH THEM MEDICAL
LEADERSHIP- WHO WOULD HAVE BEEN.
OKAY AND- I DON'T THAT ANYBODY
HAVE WITH MODELS IN AND OKAY
HOW GREATER OUR BROTHER YOU'RE
AN DR THERE IT WAS THERE PEOPLE
AT CDC ARE ADVISING YOU ON ON
WHAT AN APPROPRIATE LOCATION
ONCE. BROWN'S YOU KNOW I KNOW I
MEAN IT WOULD BE DR THERE IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN OTHERS- ON THE
STAFF ABOUT. BUT A DECISION
ABOUT WHERE TO MOVE. SURE BUT
DATE THAT YOU WOULD HAVE
SOMEONE AT CDC ARE SAYING THIS
IS THE THIS IS THE TYPE OF
FACILITY THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE
AND WHERE THEIR CHOICES OF
FACILITIES OR THERE WAS ONE
PERSON AT CDC ARE SANE. THE ONE
FACILITY. NO I DON'T THINK OF
ANYBODY ELSE THE ECR WAS
TELLING US WHICH FACILITY I
DON'T WE HAVE IN A DIFFERENT
BOX THERE- BURKE CORRECTION
SERVICES. AT THE TIME WHAT WAS
DALY CONSTANT CONTACT WITH C.
C. R. AND B. ALBUMS AND CDCR.
THERE WERE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT-
IS THIS APPROPRIATE. I WOULD
NOT HAVE EXPECTED CDC ARE THEIR
CUSTODY SIDE TO IT SO HAVE. A
VIEW. FROM. A HEALTHCARE
PERSPECTIVE. SO BY THE CHURCH
BEEN A GRACIOUS WITH ME FIVE
ONE LAST QUESTION YOU YOU. SAID
THAT SAN QUENTON WAS THE PLACE
TO GO THAT THAT THERE IS A PLAN
A PLACE TO SEND PEOPLE AND DO
TESTING BUT THERE WAS NO PLAN
FOR TESTING. THE NIGHT THAT
THEY ARRIVED WHERE THERE WERE
WERE SYMPTOMATIC PASSENGERS ON
THE BUS- THERE WAS NO CAPACITY
TO TEST AT SAN QUENTIN PEOPLE
ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO COMMUNITY
HOSPITALS TO GET THEIR TASKS.
THERE THERE IS NOTHING THERE
FOR THEM TO TEST AND NOTHING
THERE FOR ADEQUATE- QUARANTINE.
THE STILL SAY THAT YOU HAD A
PLAN TO TEST WHEN THEY ARRIVED
AT SOME POINT. BECAUSE I THINK
I NEED TO DO BEFORE AND I THINK
THE ORANGE ORDER REVEALS. THERE
WERE CONVERSATIONS WITH SAM
POINT. WHERE THEY KNEW THAT
THEY SHOULD. HAVE TESTED AND
WARRANTY. THE FACT THAT HAVE A
LITTLE MORE SLOWLY THAN IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN. AND I DON'T
KNOW A LITTLE MEAN THAT.
FRANKLY THIS FRIEND I THINK
THEY JUST WANT. THERE WERE TOO
MANY CASES THEM ABOUT THE
SAMPLE. IN NOVEMBER UP BEING A
OUT OF PLACE. BOB HAVE ANY.
OPEN CASES. THANKS PLAN WAS
SIMPLY. USE THE FORM SPACE A
LITTLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU IF
NO ONE ELSE WITH ANY OTHER.
THANK YOU I WOULD JUST- WE'RE
GOING TO GO ON TO ISSUE THE IN
IN A MINUTE BUT I WHICH IS. I
RECOMMEND THAT WE HERE THE
MEMBERS FRUSTRATIONS THAT THE
STATUS QUO ISN'T WORKING. AND
THAT WE EXPECT- THAT WE EXPECT
THAT WE EXPECT THE CDC ARE TO
CORRECT- THE PORES THEY'VE BEEN
ON WE WANT TO GET TO THE POINT
WHERE IF YOU HAVE CONFIDENCE-
AND THE WORK YOU'RE DOING BUT I
WOULD SAY THAT IT'S CLEAR THAT
WE'RE LACKING THAT I WHEN WE'RE
GETTING ANSWERS LIKE. WE'RE NOT
SURE WE NOTHING HAS CHANGED OUT
THERE ARE AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THINGS DO CHANGE
BECAUSE IT COMES WITH LIABILITY
TO OUR TAX DOLLARS JUST
RECENTLY OF CALLOUS OR FIND THE
FIND THE DEPARTMENT FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
CODE VIOLATIONS AND THAT
THEY'RE NOT THE FIRST. AND OUR
TAXPAYERS ARE PAYING FOR THAT
FOR THE VIOLATIONS AND SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE DOING
ALL WE CAN TO AVOID THE
VIOLATIONS THAT IS TO KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE BUT ALSO TO PROTECT
THE TAX DOLLARS FOR ALL THE
OTHER SERVICES THAT WE NEED OUT
THERE. SO WITH THAT I'M GONNA
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER. THREE
THANK YOU FOR THE REFERRAL NOW
GIVE US A BRIEF UPDATE OF THE
QUALITY MANAGEMENT AND PATIENT
SAFETY BUDGET PROPOSAL AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- OUT OF JAIL-
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES REQUEST A FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND.
AND THE THREE POSITIONS IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. OF SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND OF THE
FORTY FIVE POSITIONS IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND ELEVEN
POINT SEVEN BILLION GENERAL
FUND IN SEVENTY FIVE POSITIONS.
IN. TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
AND THEN ONGOING. WHICH IS TWO
WEEKS. THE QUALITY MAY SYSTEM.
THAT WILL HELP US TO BETTER
ADDRESS PATIENT SAFETY RISKS.
THE REQUESTED THE RESERVE
MIDDLEBURG WEST WAS ORIGINALLY
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WELL WAS
WITHDRAWN BEFORE PASSAGE OF THE
BUDGET ACTIONS TO PROMOTE- THE
PROPOSAL HAS BEEN MODIFIED. TO
HAVE A PHASES. ABOUT THREE
YEARS INSTEAD OF WHO IS HAVING
THE PRIOR PROPOSAL. THE WORK OF
SAFETY WELL LAST. AND CALL
MANAGEMENT BEEN PRIMARILY. FROM
HIM. IN THE WORK OF THE DON'T
AND THEN I WAS DRUM ALL THE
QUALITY- MANAGEMENT PUNITIVE
THE ONE WITH FOR ALL BREAK DOWN
WORKS DURING AND THEY PRODUCED
WELL ALMOST FIFTY NEW YORK.
JEFF LONG COLD AFTER A OF ALL
SORTS OF STATE. READ MORE. THE
pDELIVERED THE INSTANCE. IN EACH
THE VISION NEED ALL COMPONENT
OF QUALITY. AND PATIENT SAFETY.
BOB THIS EXPAND IS OFTEN
RECOMMENDED TO US ALL FIRE
OUTSIDE SALT WOULD NEED OF
CALIFORNIA SANTA. ESSENTIALLY
WITH ALL ONE MODERN HEALTHCARE
SYSTEMS AROUND THE COUNTRY ARE
DOING TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
CARE. SO WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR SUPPORT. WEST. THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR L. A.
O. HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- JUST
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE L.
A. L. HAS PRESENTED A CONCERN-
WITH THE FACT THAT THIS.
PROPOSAL INCLUDES POSITIONS FOR
THE PEOPLE OF OCCASIONAL
INTERESTING AND WE ARE WORKING
ON CORRECTING THIS AND EXPECT.
FOR MORE WITH THE L. A. L. IN
ADDITION TO THAT THIS IS NOT.
GONNA MENTION THERE'S ALSO
ANOTHER KIND CLOSER OR CLOSER.
YOU TO BE ADDRESSED ADVOGADOS
COMMITTEE STRUCTURE DOWN THE-
ROAD ALLOCATED TO BECAUSE IT IS
THAT EACH OF THE THIRTY FIVE
PERSONS. FIVE ORGANIZATIONS
PLANNING BECAUSE T. I. M. THE
BILL BECAME LAW INSTITUTION.
AND TWENTY ONE POINT TO ANOTHER
UNNAMED PERSON IN TWENTY FOUR
SORRY THAT IT SHOULD BE A TOTAL
FOR POSITIONS OUR REDUCE NOW
HERE'S- PORTAL ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE IN. THE
GENERAL FUND OKAY. THANK YOU- I
WILL NOW LOOK AT IT UP FOR
MICHAEL TO THE ANY. ON NUMBER
TWO. WE HAVE WE HAVE NO FIVE.
OUT FOR MY COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
AND SO. I WILL MOVE ON BE
MINDFUL OF TIME- THANK THE
PANELISTS. AND I WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENTS.
BOTH IN THE HEARING ROOM AND ON
THE PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE THE AGENDA AND SHOULD
ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE
STREAMING THE HEARING. JUST IN
CASE THE NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S.
877-692-8957 IN THE ACCESS
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN AGAIN
THAT'S. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. IF YOU ENCOUNTER
ANY PROBLEMS PETE PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2090 NINE
AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU. WE ALSO ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AS WELL THIS
CAN BE SUBMITTED AT BUDGET SUB
FIVE AT ASM DOT CA DOT GOV IT
IS ALSO LISTED ON THE AGENDA.
FIRST WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS IN
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WHO WISH
TO SPEAK. PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND. SCENE NO ONE OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONELINE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT EACH PERSON HAS
A TWO ONE MINUTE FOR THE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO ASK-
SHARE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. THEY REMOVE YOURSELF
FROM QUEUE AT ANY TIME BY
REPEATING THE ONE ZERO COMMAND
IF YOU ARE USING A SPEAKERPHONE
PLEASE PICK UP THE HANDSET
BEFORE PRESSING THE NUMBERS
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SHARE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AT THIS TIME TH
AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE. OPERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN THE. WE DO
OR GIVING THEM THEIR NUMBER AT
THIS TIME AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE A COMMENT
AND OUR PERSICO COMMENT COMES
FROM A LINE NINE LINE NINE
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. LODGEMENT BROWN I
AM A RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA. MY
COMMENT IS THE- I. G. REPORT IS
CLEAR AND CONVINCING EVIDENCE.
THAT CDCR CANNOT SAFELY HOW ARE
PROVIDE MEDICAL CARE FOR THOSE
IN CUSTODY. HUMANITY AND PUBLIC
HEALTH MUST BE OVER SLAVERY. IT
HAS BEEN ALMOST A YEAR SINCE
THE OUTBREAK NCDC ARW HAS
REFUSED TO FOLLOW THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERT. YOU CANNOT CUT
CORNERS DURING A PANDEMIC. CDCR
HAVE THE VERIFIED LIST OF HIGH
RISK PEOPLE THAT MAY BE
RELEASED AND POLLED BELIEVE ARE
NO THREAT TO PUBLIC SAFETY MY
BROTHER BELIEVES BROWN WITH
IMMUNO COMPROMISED. HE SIGNED
PEARL CONDITIONS BACK IN AUGUST
OF TWENTY TWENTY AND WOULD
NEVER RELEASE HE HAS BEEN LEFT
IN CUSTODY TO DIE. SINCE
SIGNING KAROQ HE HAS BEEN MARK
TIMES. EVEN THOUGH HE AFFECTED
BASED TIME AND COMPLETELY
REHABILITATED WITH A STRONG
SUPPORT SYSTEM AWAITING HIS
RETURN HOME TO ASSURE A
SUCCESSFUL RE ENTRY WITH NO
LIKELIHOOD OF RECIDIVISM. AND
ALTHOUGH SECRETARY ALISON HAS-
STATED THAT SHE'S MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR ELEVEN
SEVENTY REFERRAL THAT IS NOT
SUFFICIENT BECAUSE THIS IS A
BIG PROCESS MUST BE IMMEDIATE
AND ELEVEN SEVENTY TAKES TIME
ESPECIALLY FOR GOLD AS MYSELF
IN L. A. COUNTY. WHERE WE ARE
AT STANFIELD SO WE ARE ASKING
FOR. COMMITTING TO DO WHAT THEY
CAN TO ENFORCE ACTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEGASONIC YOU AGAIN
IT AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE
A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE. IF WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. L. AS MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE HAVE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS BEFORE WE ADJOURN FOR
TODAY. THIS IS THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK AHEAD OF US. I THINK
THAT'S VERY CLEAR AND I THINK
THAT'S VERY- VERY CLEAR THAT-
THE CHALLENGES AHEAD OF US ARE
CRITICAL. AS WERE ACTUALLY
TALKING ABOUT. THE POTENTIAL
PEOPLE LOSING THEIR LIFE SO. WE
NEED TO BE RESPONSIBLE. THANK
YOU MISTER LUCKY I WANT TO
THANK OUR PANELISTS FOR BEING
HERE AND OUR MEMBERS AND THE
PUBLIC FOR PARTICIPATION FOR
PARTICIPATING IN I WANT TO ECHO
MISTER LUCKY SENTIMENT THAT
IT'S LIFE AND DEATH- AND I HOPE
THAT WE GET IT WE DO A BETTER
MOVING FORWARD I APPRECIATE
EVERYONE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
OUR NEXT HEARING THIS VIDEO AS
IT TURNED.